Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
It's a very exciting weekend.
There's lots of talk about,
um,
but of course we have some business to attend to.
Jean,
I am going to,
going to,
I'm going to do,
you're only going to get to,
I'm going to be in Richmond,
Virginia.
The first show is sold out July 11th.
We added a late show,
few tickets left for that Virginia Beach.
The next day sold out.
Greensboro has a few tickets left.
Asheville,
North Carolina sold out.
Charleston,
South Carolina on July 15th.
Not sold out.
Plenty of tickets.
So many tickets.
Uh,
from there I go to Montreal,
Hampton Beach,
Canadian,
Yep.
Uh,
Wilmington,
Delaware and balls and whores,
Maryland.
Oh,
then off to mum,
straight AALIYAH.
We do have to know,
I have a ton of fall dates.
They're all on sale.
Tom Cigarette out ti.com/tour.
Please go ahead and check those out.
We do have to announce that unfortunately,
due to unforeseen circumstances,
the mom cast,
um,
that we had planned July 9th,
uh,
we're not able to do it that day.
Show business guys,
it's show business.
We are honoring every ticket sold,
um,
at the October 8th Irvine show.
So if you're,
if you're in sperm vine,
if you want to go to that show,
we're doing the podcast live 10,
eight October eight.
Your tickets that you had for July 9th are good on October 8th.
If you're not available to come to that,
you can get a full refund.
So there's no problem with that.
We're also doing the podcast live August 23rd in breath balls beach.
That's the West Palm Beach Improv in Florida.
Breastbone.
So,
um,
make sure you check that out.
Gene.
Anything else?
No,
I'm taking a break now for a while after a shooting that special.
Let's get into that after.
Yeah,
after the break here because there's a lot to go over with it.
I'm just doing,
um,
that's deep brown doing your mom's house.
So check out that deep,
Bro.
If you haven't already,
I talk about some real life shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey,
wow.
Talk some shit.
Please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Shop through the Amazon banner,
any Amazon shopping you were going to do.
Um,
if you do it through
our banner,
it gets a little kickback to the show and it greatly helps the show.
So if you like our show and you can do it,
there's a Canadian banner and a UK banner as well as the regular us banner and
uh,
it's very,
you know,
it's very helpful.
Here we go.
January to start the show.
Super Ready Bro.
Do with gene,
the south Florida man accused of killing his girlfriend.
Continue today and so far no rolling on.
If he'll be able to show his penis to the jury like he requested for more on the
soil.
Let's get some local tense.
Carlos Suarez has been following this both Fort Lauderdale.
Carlos,
don't bring in one.
Loving to this.
Well,
go to your mom's house.
Christina pushes it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Fort Lauderdale,
Fort Lauderdale's Fart.
Louder.
Dale.
Semen,
whole God and come see.
Come see now.
Right cock and come see no fart.
Louder Day.
I think that was one of the first cities we started to make fun.
I know because that was like such a hard cock.
Come see.
No,
it was just right there.
The hard cock casino.
It was right there.
Uh,
those reporters were super attractive.
It's south Florida.
Is that,
was that why?
Yeah,
of course.
Miami adjacent.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
it's attractive people of course.
Seriously.
Miami,
La Jude.
Titties.
Good looking people on the news especially.
Yeah.
And this is the,
the Latin vibes.
So they gotta be sexy.
I mean,
you,
you've never seen a female anchor that looks like a rock,
right?
No pigs allowed.
No,
no,
not in Fort Lauderdale.
And the weather girls usually have like the cut on down there.
Why is that Tom?
Uh,
I think the Latins demanded.
Why
not say hey,
sexy?
No.
Why?
What is it with the Latins and the sexy?
What is that?
Miami sex culture is crazy.
I remember talking to guys now who,
you know,
are adults now about middle school and they're like,
yeah,
we were fucking in in fifth grade.
And my favorite,
by the way,
are you talking about who was fucking in hell?
The kids pacifically who pacifically kids kind of children.
What do you mean?
Like who all the kids are?
That's what he was,
he was saying that one of my friends was saying that,
that you'd be made fun of,
you know,
like that's what you'd be teased about.
Like,
Oh,
you haven't been fucking yet.
It was like 10,
11 years old,
I think.
But you know,
you see the footage from carnival in Brazil,
you know,
titties out,
ass out.
It's also,
it's less thought of as taboo,
you know,
it's not,
they're just like,
oh yeah,
people have sex.
I think it's a little hyper.
Uh,
yeah,
but still they're,
they're not making it this dangerous,
but the very thing,
the irony is,
is that they're deeply Catholic.
So then you have,
that is ironic,
this weird juxtaposition of like hypersexual and then hyper cath lab and they
loved their mothers.
It's a very maternal cultural,
it's like,
do you want to fuck or do you want to fucking feel guilty?
Or do you want to fuck your mom?
Fuck your mom.
Um,
remember when we were in Puerto Rico,
my holy grail and I felt like I was visiting the Wailing Wall,
you know what I mean?
For me it was just that personnel to to finally go to Puerto Rico.
Of course,
remember the towels,
they would sell beach towels that were just like naked boners just naked people
aren't like painted.
Oh,
sexual.
Yeah.
How's that man who's around,
who's Yo know smells like
sexual,
not sexual,
not sexual guys.
It's just pile a bunch of guys just hanging out,
just hanging,
being real,
being guys.
That's so funny.
See,
I'll see.
Eastern blockers were pretty sexual too,
but we keep it,
no,
like they make out in public like the kids.
So that's because everyone lives with their parents.
I remember semester abroad and Spain was um,
a lot.
You saw a lot.
I mean I was in Madrid lot of middle,
like a public teenage may counts a lot like you would,
it was,
it was overwhelming.
But oddly enough,
like when I was in Peru,
which is South America,
Latin culture,
very Catholic,
they were much more,
I think they were obviously doing things,
but um,
it wasn't a public thing you put on a public face of a little more reserved
decorum.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Yo,
come on,
hold it together.
A pig.
But I mean that's Peru and then right over here in Brazil and it's totally
different cities.
They just fucking,
the streets in Brazil,
right?
I don't know if they fucking the streets,
but they definitely get their asses out.
They let their asses out,
enter titties out everywhere.
Dude.
You go to south beach and you see those titties everywhere.
Yeah,
that's right.
All kinds of teddy.
Just like the gays.
But I like that culture.
I feel comfortable in that.
I feel totally comfortable around all Latin cultures.
Very familiar.
I like it.
I like it too.
I,
you know,
my own tribe makes me a little uncomfortable by the way.
Same to me.
Eastern buggers.
It's all about making you feel not welcome.
I feel like uncomfortable.
It's just harder.
Their heart more hardcore.
Also this whole thing about showing emotion is bad.
See,
it's one thing,
weakness,
overly emotional thing can be overwhelming,
like overly emotional people and you're like cool.
But the one thing that's nice is you always know where someone's standing.
You know what I mean?
Like you're not guessing when you read someone.
Yeah.
So like with,
with what's common among like the Latin people is like,
you know when they're upset,
you know when they're happy,
you know when they like something,
you know when they're excited and then that's this coldness thing where you go
like,
does the person not like me or does the person upset?
And they're like,
no,
that's just normal.
But that's,
that takes a lot of getting used to because they're not giving you a clear
signal.
Yeah.
See I actually,
I view it the opposite because in Latin culture sometimes they're so polite that
they don't tell you like from me,
I have to be hit over the head because I grew up that way.
They just tell you like you're fucking piece of shit and you,
that's how you communicate.
I'm actually used to a more over the head form of communication.
Like we were talking today,
like our nannies,
very Latin and demean like she doesn't come out.
Sometimes we have to kind of be,
she can't hide it.
She does.
She'll,
she's very,
she will satisfy you,
but she will not 100% hide how she feels.
So if you go,
if you go,
do you mind staying later today?
She'll go,
sure.
It's so obvious at that point that she doesn't want it to,
so you go,
do you have plans after?
Well,
okay,
so then do that.
Don't worry.
Like I could adjust my thing.
You don't have to stay late.
Oh,
she's so sweet.
But he wouldn't go like,
no,
I have something to do and my family a big go fuck yourself.
I have to do something that you're,
you're intruding in my life.
You're ruining my life.
Uh,
she's so sweet.
We have a housekeeper that we've had for years too.
She's from,
she's Cuban and last week she was here cleaning and there's been an evolution in
her phone game.
Yeah.
Like at first it was like occasionally she'd be on her phone cleaning the house,
taking calls.
Cause you're like,
oh yeah,
you're,
you're doing like busy.
Why you don't need to think a whole,
you know,
it's,
it's busy work essentially.
Like you have to think but not,
it's not focused.
And then it evolved to like the Bluetooth,
right?
Like was there a oh no,
no,
she would use the air piece.
It's the earpiece evolved to like if I walked in the room,
I'd never say anything.
If I walked in the room,
which was on the phone,
I would hear her in Spanish obviously say like,
oh I got go it when the implication was the,
you know,
the my employer.
Right.
So I'm going to end this nonsense right now.
Now
if I walk in the room and she's on the phone,
she'll be like,
yeah,
I talk louder.
Like this guy fucking here.
But anyways,
so if later on,
if you guys want to get together and like come completely disregarding,
find it highly
amusing.
So do I have no,
actually I know she does a great job.
It doesn't interfere with the work.
She gets to talk to her friends.
Why not?
Uh,
but now it's evolved to,
she just puts them on speaker phone and then puts the phone on the counter.
So now we hear both sides of the conversation in Spanish,
which is fine too.
It,
it is funny though because she'll be like,
wait,
who's talking?
Oh,
it's,
it's our cleaning lady.
She's on the phone with somebody again and she's always like,
I know
that was always her with ing bank.
better.
Better why she did this.
She say that alone.
Yeah.
They have a really interesting accent.
Cubans.
I like how she'd speak Spanish.
It's cool.
I heard her one time,
uh,
[inaudible] speak Spanish.
You here?
Um,
nanny speaks Spanish and here my most expanse and you have those say specific
sentences,
you will hear it just like you're hearing an American,
a Brit and like a Scottish person.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's tall dialect.
Wholly different.
But they understand each other.
It's the same language,
but their accents and their slang is 100% different,
right?
Yeah.
Just like America,
just like,
just like the case.
It's just like the gays.
Yeah.
Um,
I was,
I gonna say now I remember.
Thanks.
Well,
how about this?
We have kind of a celebratory thing going on right now.
You shot your first special,
now I'm so exhausted and I'm so happy and I'm so grateful we didn't tell
anybody.
But you came,
I came up there and you opened for me.
I know.
That was so fun and it was the best surprise ever to the audience and they
freaked out and people really seem to enjoy that.
Yeah.
The jeans were one pair and I'm so glad you came with me,
Jean.
I'm so thankful because I mean,
I was always planning on going with for months and you know,
just going to be your support and you know,
just make sure everything's going well and you have what you need.
And then a few weeks ago you were just like,
I think he was you.
You said like,
would you open?
And I was like,
yeah,
of course.
It's never occurred to me,
think about it,
who,
you know,
offer it or anything.
But they ended up being very,
really fun.
Yeah.
It was Super Fun and I'm so glad you were there just so that I didn't freak out
day of the guy.
I didn't freak out.
I freaked out three months ago,
you know when you know like,
Oh shit,
there's a,
there's a date now.
Like there's a fucking thing and then day of,
Oh,
I could sleep the night before I was fine,
but then I felt myself around 2:00 PM yeah.
Getting into hair and makeup.
That's when like the terrorist started to kick.
Yeah.
I was glad you were there just to have somebody I to talk to that spoke my
language also got like such an interesting perspective because it was the first
time that I was really close to someone,
but I'm not the one doing it where you're seeing the day evolve,
but you don't feel the pressure of doing the show.
Right.
The pressure on you,
it's all for you.
And that's the Friday.
And then I know,
I understand why the managers and the producers are like,
screw it.
Just do your thing.
Because that's exactly what it felt like.
Yeah.
Big Deal.
Just when we walked over there,
I was like,
beautiful day.
Then you looks great just to your fucking show.
What's your problem?
Yeah.
That's not that big of a deal.
And go down.
What's your problem?
Right?
You pick your Pronoun,
get out there and be Pauline by.
Yeah.
And the thing is,
it really isn't.
And the,
at the end of the day,
because we've done it for so many years and once,
once I got up there,
it was like,
oh,
this is my second home,
but a pronoun.
But the it,
it's,
it's a little overwhelming when you walk in and there's this whole thing and
then it's all for you.
There's many cameras,
there's screens,
there's producers,
there's people talking to you person,
crew and yeah.
Yeah.
It is not a,
this is not your friend being like,
Hey,
are you free this afternoon to do this thing?
Yeah.
It's a lot of money and a lot of people's livelihoods essentially.
Here's the thing that's so crazy that the reason that there is very,
and the reason why you all
always have some form of anxiety on a shoot days.
You just never know how it's going to go.
Yeah.
And then afterwards,
like luckily for you,
I can tell you that like,
man,
it's got to feel good because it went so well,
was amazing and you know,
you like,
and you know it's captured,
you know,
it's like when you shoot these things,
you,
you could be on tour.
I'll tell you,
the first one I did was in Minneapolis.
I'm sorry,
where?
Minneapolis tits.
Okay.
And I know people will say,
you know,
oh,
are you trying to be dramatic?
I promise you this,
of the hundred and 50 shows leading up to that taping in Minneapolis,
that was the worst show of the hundred and fifth
taping day was the worst show of this,
of all the shows leading up to it.
No,
I swear to God like the audience was just shit.
Yes.
God Damn it.
It was terrible.
And this is completely normal.
Yes.
Oh my God.
Which ended up being like,
oh,
ended up best help special that everyone loves and red.
But that's so fun.
Lesson for that for me was that was because it was well received by,
by some people you know,
at home.
Yeah.
You realize that even with what I experienced,
ultimately you're performing for the people at home.
Yes.
It's television.
There were jokes that fell so flat that I was used to getting such a big laugh
on there was,
it was just like,
it was one of those things where you're like,
you know,
I,
I was like,
well,
and this is just what it is.
And Dan is,
yeah.
But,
but yeah,
killing his girlfriend continues today and so far no rolling on.
If we'll be able to show his penis.
I like,
I'd kind of glad that we got to see like call those Suarez has been following
this Carlos Torres.
That's a Latin name.
Yup.
But I wanted to say that ultimately,
you know,
you have the,
the,
the best part of it,
which is that people are going to enjoy it at home,
but people in the audience loved it.
Yeah.
It was,
it was fine.
It was really,
and it was a really,
I was there,
I was really,
here's the thing,
it took me 14 years to get here.
Amazing.
And I'm kind of glad it took that long because I think had I done this,
we were just talking about this this morning.
Had I done this even five years ago,
three years ago,
I would have been shitting in my pants.
Yeah.
So think it took like it took,
it took longer and I'm glad it did.
I'm thankful for it because it gave me the time to calm the fuck down and just
like enjoy him and enjoy the day.
I was actually more sad about about it being over,
you know,
and you're like,
oh,
now I don't have that thing to look forward to anymore.
Like that's kind of gone.
I'll tell you guys,
one funny thing that happened during the taping.
So,
uh,
halfway through the first show,
you know,
the,
they get out and they tell you guys,
hey,
don't,
don't get up and take a piss.
Don't pay your fallen out because we're taping and it interferes with the camera
as blah,
blah,
blah.
So halfway through my set and maybe less a quarter away,
I hear
some nasty motherfucker got up and was flushing the toilet and you can hear it
in the showroom and I was like,
I got to hold for sound.
Like I can't just tell my joke through toilet flushing.
Then it ended up being like this crazy moment and I'm like,
who is shitting in the middle of my shoe?
So funny.
And flushing and flushing and flushing like it was so perfect for your mom's
house essentially for people to be there and someone taking a shit in my show,
like doing asshole.
There's two ways things can go in a show.
Something happens and your instinct can be to get upset.
This is right.
Right,
right,
right.
Roll with that.
Thank you.
And um,
it'll be interesting to see whether you keep it in,
I don't know if I will and you'll see it in the,
in the line cut and you'll see whether or not you want it in.
But it was in to experience it from where I was and to see you keep going with
it was really funny.
Well,
I don't know if you know this.
I mean,
I don't mean to be talking to an attorney or,
but I am the queen of Improv.
Oh yeah.
I don't mind you saying it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's really,
you were very,
your improv skills were really good there.
Well,
I'm really,
um,
I'm really thankful to have you there on the best part of it seriously was
having you there and,
and knowing that the mommy's wearing in the audience supporting me and laughing
and that was so special.
I think it's always special when it's you,
me and the mommies.
I just love it.
It was,
I really do love it.
We really had,
it really was a fun,
fun night.
Special.
Very special.
My cousin Julie came down.
She and her husband live in Washington now,
so it's good to see her too,
and you know.
Yeah,
it was special.
Very cool.
I look gray.
I love my outfit.
My jeans were high,
super tight.
Are you going to wear jeans on your next tape course?
I've always worn jeans.
I wear jeans under my,
under the dress that I wear.
Do you want to go back to this news thing?
Right.
I would love to go back to this new thing.
Obviously you just,
you heard the clip of the jury or they haven't decided whether the defendant can
show his penis to the jury.
Yeah.
The associate medical examiner,
Broward County,
took to the sand about an hour ago and said that in all his years of work,
he has never had a single case where someone choked to death as a result of
performing oral sex.
So,
uh,
oh.
His testimony goes to the heart of the defense's case that Richard Patterson did
not kill his girlfriend back in 2015 prosecutors allege that these 65 year old
choked to death,
but he claims that she choked on his penis.
The Emmy told jurors a penis would have to be large,
far enough down a person's throat to block that person from breathing through
their nose and a mouth.
He also said that it would take two to three minutes for a person to die as a
result of a lack of oxygen so that it would have been back here.
That person,
this woman in distress
to show the jury his penis how big it is.
Yeah.
You could choke on this.
You know,
here's the medical examiner
and if she can win,
she's usually start.
Well,
speaking of that,
yeah.
Yes.
My tribe
Z is blocking off the airway,
opens his airways.
It's normal reaction in the first one.
So he's saying she should be flailing and biding and you know,
flipping out because she can't breathe.
Right.
I mean,
here's the thing,
as someone that has done this before,
done what?
Nothing.
I kissed PBS before so many before you got that.
Uh,
you kind of know when you can't breathe,
so why wouldn't you just put your mouth,
get your mouth away from it?
So he must have choked her.
He was probably pushing her head down.
My ass.
Yeah.
It's my friend Rocco.
Yup.
All right.
Now the defense has asked a judge whether Patterson can show jurors his penis as
part of their case is not Sam on whether that will be allowed to take place.
Medical Examiner also told jurors that he could not rule on a matter of death
because the body of 60 year old Francisco Martinez was in such bad shape when it
was found inside her morgate home.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That means what though?
That it sat around for a long time in bad shape.
I don't know.
She's hot though,
right?
The judge there.
Now,
for our listeners,
could you describe the defendant?
I mean,
they don't know they're there.
Yeah,
he's a old ass dad.
I mean,
he's got red skin,
all white hair,
white hair like Santa's without a beard.
Yeah.
I mean you wouldn't even expect this guy has a dick anymore.
No.
Or that it gets hard then it gets big enough to choke people.
Yeah.
I doubt that he's real old is similar to the premise of a tod Sha,
Aka two short song blowjob,
Betty.
Right.
And was she bust a nut and killed a bitch.
But that's from the nut.
I know that's why there's a distinction,
but it is similar in the premise where they both their dicks both were involved
in murder.
That's interesting.
What a neat point.
I wish you would bring that up to the judge.
Yup.
The medical examiner is still on the stand and the defense says that spelled did
not call nine one one the night that this happened because he was embarrassed
about the whole thing.
So just whenever you want to know something,
why not guilty?
He was found not guilty.
Seriously.
Yeah.
Not guilty.
I think he choked her.
I do.
I do to on accident and was super big PP.
How could you choke yourself on someone's Dick?
That's stupid.
He killed her.
Yup.
They should rethink that shit.
What the fuck?
How old is this guy?
He was 65 at the time,
so now he's 67 well he nasty house.
No nasty.
Where your big o you big old,
Stinky Dick.
You know,
I found this to finally pulled from,
from the episode my parents were on target.
I might be retired.
I go retarded.
Retarded.
That's interesting.
In already picked retarded.
I didn't realize how popular a choice that would be.
Personally.
I would take the sexual abuse from my Granddad,
but you know,
cause then you can just go to therapy and deal with that.
But you can't treat retarded.
You can't really treat it.
But some people really hate the other option,
I guess.
Yes.
I mean from my dad it was just Asian food.
All right.
Let me think about how much you have to,
I hate that.
I love Korean barbecue and I love Sushi.
I can't even imagine.
I mean obviously I would just be like Asian food forever.
Of course.
All Day,
every day.
I love Asian.
That's one of my favorite cuisines of the world.
What could you eat every day?
I know steak.
I do love meat.
I could eat that a lot.
You had Sushi the other day and it gave me diarrhea.
You don't learn,
I don't think no more.
You just keep eating it in the bear.
Keeps eating and shitting everywhere.
I just,
you know,
it was fun
cause I ain't afraid of him.
You know what's so funny?
Yesterday we flew home on virgin.
Yeah.
And uh,
are,
are fried.
Attended.
Her name was Debbie.
Yeah.
It was so stupid.
We were like,
you were you making whatever.
She's really nice though.
It was nice,
by the way,
the driver to the airport and he was flying to Virginia Airlines.
I go virgin.
He goes,
okay,
why don't you do this drive all the time?
Because the airport,
who's flying Virginia Air Weirdo that he clearly,
it wasn't like a little slip up.
He goes,
Virginia air today,
that many deaf people fly to Virginia from here.
So weird.
Yeah.
So she was Debbie and I was like,
Hey,
uh,
you're see that movie Debbie Does Dallas?
And she goes,
no.
I go,
you know,
it's about,
are you going to do everybody on the plane?
She was like,
yeah,
I think so.
Let me go,
where are you going to start in front of their back?
They're going to start at the back.
I guess.
That's quite a job.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if that was apologize?
When we land she goes,
I'm sorry.
I didn't get to do everybody.
Just trying to everyone,
but I couldn't,
that's a tear.
Okay.
So what of that's your job?
Maybe that's a good,
would you rather ooh.
Oh,
does that mean nasty at all?
Be Nasty.
It's all,
but it really is all mental.
It's can you remove yourself?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's,
can you remove yourself from the horror of doing all of these people?
Or can you like separate yourself?
Like you're,
you know,
think of yourself like a kidnap victim or something.
You know?
Would you rather be Debbie,
the flight attendant who has to do the entire plane,
who or Saigon,
that old guy's weaning
weight and potentially die?
Or can I back off if I'm choking that the potential for death is there,
is there,
but you got to just suck it once for,
here's the thing.
People are saying,
Oh,
do I know they're going,
dude.
Obviously it'd be her.
You don't have to suck that guy's Dick.
But on the plane there might be 80 guys say 80 dicks.
Yeah.
It's like the old guys did
for sure.
I was like,
that'll guy's dick too.
Over doing the whole plane.
You know how many nasty,
ugly people
he might kill him now.
Don't buy that.
I would know when I was choking and then I shot,
probably didn't do and he probably held on and that's how she died.
He's too old.
Fuck him.
Could you imagine blowing just a random plane of people?
You might,
any gross people are on airplanes.
There was fat ones,
skinny ones,
greasy ones,
smelling ones.
I was on a plane last week where,
um,
uh,
this kid was taking a shit and first class we've,
we reveal later.
It was a teenage boy and anyway,
the guy was in there for 20 minutes.
The flight attendant was knocking on,
knocking on the door.
I finally,
he gets out.
It's a teenage Asian kidneys fat.
Took a big shit and it stinks so bad that the guy in front of me refused to go
in and take a piss.
I was like,
you got to Kenny.
And then this hiccup,
this hippie kid pushed his way in front of me and I let him go in and he's like,
what?
What's going on?
Why is everybody standing around?
And I'm like,
do I let me go?
You'll find out.
And then he's like,
I see why now.
Mrs Smelled Terrible,
smelled horrendous time.
I got on a plane and a dude,
shit came out.
Nancy stuck inside of that toilet.
So I hit flush and the water just went over it.
It smelled so bad.
And I told the flight attendant,
she goes,
oh,
I got some.
And She just had a person spray in her purse and just did like 20 sprays in
there.
And I was like,
man,
it's like an hell.
It's just putting perfume on.
That shit is all you're doing.
You know,
it's not good.
It's so gnarly.
Um,
yeah.
Here we go.
Email you to talk about
hair removal between the cheeks and have discussed waxing.
And I'm here to tell you a much easier and less invasive method to remove all
that Brown collecting for Nair.
Good old fashioned glass.
That shit on up in your cheeks while minding the more sensitive skin that is the
ball.
SACRA vulva within a couple minutes,
wipe it off with a wash cloth,
washcloth in the shower.
It gets into every book and Brown cranny and webs away the hair without having
to be humiliated by having an actual person wax your asshole.
I have much experience with this and no bad reactions.
I hope this has provided you with a much needed solution to main mother Tina's
version,
Aka excuse to not devouring your asshole.
Tommy.
Love you both.
And Christina is the life champ.
I like that life change.
That's Caroline.
That's a lady right there.
Caroline and Caroline.
I am,
I've used near on my legs and it is a very volatile chemical substance.
Yeah.
It smells really bad and strong.
So she's right.
You gotta be real careful about it touching your,
your kibbles and bits.
So if you put on your ass hole,
I mean,
I don't know how she does it.
She,
she must have a lot of experience because that,
that is true.
I'll try it.
It really will burn you gotta be careful if you get it on your tender tender
zones.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah,
it's real.
It's hold them up for a little bit.
How long have you leave it on for a couple minutes.
Yeah.
It's quite near like burns the hair off.
That's I think how it works.
Like a chemical burn.
I'm going to try it.
It's pretty gnarly.
Hey,
you got to get your teeth whitened before.
I know you do your stuff.
People keep telling me online they're commenting and how yellow your teeth?
No,
you gotta get your teeth whitened.
You do.
Especially if we're going to shoot something.
Here we go.
Oh,
this guy,
when he worked at Ballpark,
they made us do a chant in our meetings.
Oh my God.
We had those last week and they were just ball for our Walmart.
Yeah.
God.
Shabu shabu you think about,
you know it's Shibuya was so horrible that I think about it.
Yeah.
Every now and then I'll be like in our closet
and I'll think about those poor people.
God,
Oh my God.
So bad,
right?
We are.
We are Walmart.
I know.
Especially for like,
you know,
it's not a job that you love.
No,
nobody's like a career Walmart employee.
It's a stepping stone place.
He said that when they were,
I mean,
it's a sales level,
not I'm in management stuff.
This took place in the middle of the store in front of customers.
I went like this,
give me a w gimme,
a gimme,
an l o,
and he said squiggly.
We had to go up and down,
shaking our butts.
Gimme an m m gimme an A.
Hey,
give me an or give me a t.
what's that spell Walmart.
I can't hear you.
What do we want?
Save people money.
How do we do it so they can live better?
Why did we decide so money,
save money.
Live better.
Woo.
Oh my God.
That was my life for two years.
It did have more personality that Mommy,
thanks Jean through to shit.
Travis.
Travis,
I liked you until that last line.
Yeah,
that's it.
Okay,
so let's go there.
Right?
Where would
you rather work at Walmart and have to do that every morning?
That so depressing or what?
Oh my God,
I,
I would,
I would be broke.
Broken spirited for sure.
But then there's this other,
I've had this job before where you call people and you solicit them to buy
tickets to things or to take surveys.
So would I rather do the sales pitch or retarded?
Okay.
No,
it's Walmart and you do that.
Or you have to go door to door and get people to like save the whales or donate
money to the children.
But you're going door to door.
I would rather do that and you have to do the pitch of like,
hi ma'am,
can I speak to you for just five minutes?
Do you have a moment?
I know it's about the same tons.
I can't so hard the cheer.
I meant too crazy.
I'd rather do the cheering.
Honestly,
it's so hard to go door to door and get rejected.
I mean I've done,
I've done the call center stuff.
That shit is hard,
man.
Ma,
can I just take five minutes of your time?
I might be doing a survey on eggs.
Did you know that eggs have lower cholesterol and impure?
Really say expected.
Yeah,
the extra may was my first job when I was 14.
Horrible,
horrible excuses.
But the fucking,
you know what it is.
I can't fail.
I can't.
Fame Team Spirit.
That's,
that's the soul crushing part is like the really give a shit about Walmart.
I know.
Of course.
That's the worst part.
They can't think that you do.
So the top,
top brass here are multibillionaires is my right.
I'm a w.
How much am I making?
12 hour.
All right.
Hmm?
Do I get healthcare?
No.
Oh,
just the CEO's.
okay.
Sweet man.
Terrible.
It does sound fun.
Oh my God.
You're a fat count again.
Mine.
He'd disgraceful.
I tell Ya
that for Bart.
Yeah.
Somebody said,
you know the,
you're a fat count again,
Mike describes the word on the street and I'm not,
I don't know if this is true.
So I don't want to talk out of court at a turn.
Whenever bet a word on the street is that he's gained his weight back.
Is that,
is that accurate?
It's pretty bad.
I mean,
that's everyone I meet when I'm doing stand up there like Burt's fat again.
Every time I go to the store,
they're like,
he was here last night and they're like,
he's a whale.
Wow.
Super enormous.
He did just post a really funny video.
Do you see it?
I,
so the whole coke,
Hulk Hogan.
You got hope.
I love hope.
Kogan yeah,
it was really funny.
His wife didn't the Hawke's wife leave him for like one of their daughters
friends,
the 20 year old boy.
I'm like,
God,
how,
how would you murder me if I did that?
Because they were together for a long time.
Hawkin
and honestly when I hear the stories it just sounds more confusing than,
than,
than raging.
I'm like,
wait,
what?
What happened?
I think I'd be like,
what are you doing?
Why?
Why are you ruining our family?
I don't understand.
I think that would break me.
Like if we have a family together,
we have like our kids are grown and then you're like,
I'm just going out with one of year one of our daughter's friends.
Yeah.
I hope you're okay with that.
Like,
no at that would make me kill me.
Solid.
Brings like people to hang out.
And then I just marry one of them.
We are marrying his friend,
uh,
Carrie.
She's my girlfriend now.
She's my wife,
Sophomore.
A lot of things she wants to do with their life.
What do you think,
and why does that marriage,
like what does that have to,
could you imagine right now,
and you've talked to 20 year olds and no offense to any 20 year old the night.
I just think that 40 is significantly different than 20 you're just in a
different place.
I'm not shitting on 20 year olds by any means,
but what do you,
what do you think that's like,
I mean,
oh,
it's gotta be torture.
I can't,
I dunno if nothing in common with a,
essentially children's other things leading up to the person doing that though.
It's not that,
it's not that they're like,
I'm just so compelled by you.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's problems and things not that list.
And then you end up there.
Yeah,
I dunno.
It's crazy.
You'd like it though.
Why would I like it marrying you?
Probably marry a Dalmatian after me,
after me with all these thoughts,
words,
blah,
blah.
Talking.
I mean,
you just want some quiet after me,
you know?
Yeah.
Like you get like a 20 year old Dalmatian.
Easy.
So that's what's next.
That's what you're saying.
Yeah.
Now not now.
After I sign has grown and it goes,
no,
you're right.
You're right.
Yeah.
And then I'll get like five more Brussels Griffon and just like be alone.
I will let know.
We'll live on the same compound.
Will do.
One of those things would be fine.
We have this big,
it's eight acres.
Uh,
you know,
the thing is that Christina and carrier friend and a totally,
that's such the 20 year old new wife name Carrie.
She made it so that the estate is appropriately adjusted and um,
you know,
uh,
Christina is taken care of it.
Carrie will also get to go to school.
Eventually.
You have a college fund for you and your wife.
She's like,
when she's ready to go to school,
she'll go,
she's a yoga instructor.
That's always who they marry.
Just teach yoga.
Here we go.
How do you know you're gay if you're blind,
love the show.
I wanted to reach out to you and thinking about the blind and wiping.
What are the ask the follow up that's been driving me crazy.
If you are blind and can see people's and see people or faces or biocides only
feel you can't see Jesus,
no one writes the fucking word right.
How do you know if you're gay or straight?
If you are blind,
how would you determine your sexual orientation?
How much I needed the answer to this question.
Let me know what you think Travis.
But these are all things people really wonder about.
This show is so important.
We're really doing important work here.
Nobody asks you to leave.
I really applaud him for as
silly as it is.
I applaud you.
That's really silly.
But he's right.
So like let's say you don't,
I mean it's a very cisgender privilege.
Ask you the question isn't like you can't ask like what do you prefer?
Blondes or Brunettes?
Oh No,
you can't even ask what your Pronoun is cause you don't know what the difference
who you're looking at.
Um,
yeah,
that's a great question.
How do you know that's such a good point?
I guess when they have sexual encounters and they touch a badge and they're
like,
you know,
people are sitting,
you know on your lap and you're hugging people and you're like,
yeah,
could you get a boner with when you hug them,
there you go.
Yeah,
that's true.
Do you like those dirty pillows mashed against you or not?
Huh?
Hmm.
So really good question.
We didn't get any closure on the wiping question.
You just know like you just know man.
You just know I like or you go no,
you use your hand to wipe and then you smell your hand.
Like why wouldn't you just smell the paper?
Why did you go to your cause this you wouldn't understand.
This is like some inside shit.
You don't know about it.
And I talked to some friends and that's what it is.
So it goes how it goes.
You're cute.
It's true.
You're lucky.
I love,
here's a another email.
It's official.
Tina is not the water stupid after episode 400 stupid has been declared.
Not only is Tom the water champ,
but due to mommy teen is cowardice of declining the water challenge.
God.
I believe the Tom also needs to be declared personality champion as well.
You can tell that once the challenge was suggested by Maria,
Tina was legitimately upset.
Proceeded to insult Tom,
not to mention the disrespectful comments about Tom's anus in the opening
minutes of the episode,
all of which are very negative personality traits.
I know I certainly wouldn't want to hang out with Christina afterwards.
We'll set it up.
So 400 all I do,
however,
believe in second chances,
nor for Mommy Tina to be a personality water champion contender,
so called black kiss should be awarded a Tom and the trip to Tahiti and exchange
for a black kid should be voided and limit.
The black kiss is upgraded into a rusty trombone.
Oh by God.
Ps,
how do you feel about user submissions of ass rips in order to get the king out
of hiding?
I know you guys have tried to contact him,
but haven't had much luck.
I believe the only way to make him return is to instigate a fart war.
God bless Kyle.
Can I tell you this?
I don't know about
farting and submitting that.
I have to tell you something.
King ash ripper,
who as many of you know is a,
a staple of the show
so much and he rejects us.
He's an amazing guy.
Great.
So a lot of you know him as a fighter and a Berber I think too.
I don't want to just paint,
put him in that box.
You know,
a big thing that he also has done that we've highlighted,
but maybe not as much as he's also a glutton and he likes to overeat and gain
weight.
You're not going to believe what he looks like now.
He has really put on some weight.
He's been doing,
he hasn't been putting out as many fart videos,
but he's been putting out the stuffing himself videos.
Well,
he's always evolving as an artist.
We've never been able to just make him do.
He's not a one trick pony,
but yeah,
but you remember how he had like the little who she got a little belly and he
was like,
oh,
I'm having donuts.
Okay.
It's been awhile.
You got to see him.
Oh God damn.
Mcdonald's.
Okay.
Is that a prosthetic belly max making dog.
God
goddamn chili dogs.
Oh,
by the way,
they shouldn't accomplished.
He's fat as fuck now.
Yeah,
you really did it,
man.
Now it's also hard fat.
It looks hard.
It's hard.
But I mean he's,
I would say he's Gillen again from the early days.
This has gotta be 60 80 pounds and this is real weight.
Real weight men that's going on with it.
I don't know.
Look at that thing.
Oh my God.
He looks pregnant.
As you can see.
Look,
you can see his belly at the bottom of the pillow.
Oh my God,
dude,
I don't like that.
I don't like it.
Here we go back to basics king.
Look,
I know the parts are what we live for,
but,
but I got to say,
I know how much you wanted this,
so I just wanted to congratulate him.
That's really cool,
man.
I wanted to point something out.
Yeah.
I feel like there's a new contest evolving between the two of us.
Firstly,
I address that previous gentleman's email about me not wanting to compete INSEAD
water consumption contest.
A,
I don't need to compete because I know I am the water channel.
You said that that day.
I mean it's very silly.
I don't need to,
it's what's known as a cop out.
It's not a cop out.
You're showboater your all when the lights are on.
The cameras are rolling.
Oh,
I'm hydrating.
First of all.
Where's your water right now?
No,
no,
no.
Really?
Where is it?
Go ahead.
Why is that?
Because I'm too hydrated.
Negative.
You're drinking coffee and that's negative water.
Everyone knows that because what am I drinking?
Oh look,
I have a Fiji water right here and this is also loaded with minerals and we
learned from our water,
Somalia,
but see the thing is I had four of those before the show and that's upsetting
lie bro.
Why are you lying?
You never even even had water today.
You lie,
you lie to them all the time.
The mommies don't even know how much you lie,
not participate in my,
God's a good point because you lie.
It's like somebody saying,
um,
I'm better at you and basketball.
Let's play.
And you go,
I already know him better,
so I'm not going to play the goddess of water.
Consumption's that's what I'm saying.
Anybody that's seen me perform live during my special,
even I had the wherewithal to drink,
uh,
bottles of water.
I mean,
I,
I'm just that
dedicated.
I don't need,
secondly,
I feel like there's a new game in town and I think I've noticed over the years,
I've known you for 12 years.
That's how long we've been together.
That generally speaking,
I'm more observant than you and I notice things and details and I read more.
I'm generally more observant and I would say that I'm the observation champ.
Thank you.
Yeah,
that's my,
go ahead.
Apply it to that would be,
and this is like I would say was on a witness stand,
right.
Amongst the least observant people at trooper.
How so?
Go ahead.
Everything goes over your head.
Like what?
Don't remember who was there.
That's a memory champ.
That's not memories involved with observation.
No,
I'm saying that in a room of things.
I know it's different.
Immediately.
I walk into my shrink's office every week and I can,
I was at a new book and on the shelf by,
yes,
it is.
She,
you're very observant.
I am sure.
Okay,
well,
I noticed everything.
Your mother coupled with a different hairstyle.
Oh my gosh.
Look at you.
You don't notice anything.
I think the idea that you're actually worked up about this and you can tell how
little I am because it's like you saying you're stronger than me and I'm like,
okay,
so I think it's cute that you'll cute.
Yeah.
It's cute that you think this and oh my gosh,
I'm so observant
clips.
I am the one that points out the interesting minutia and the details of,
no,
not only do you never do,
that's 100% me.
You should have the listeners weigh in on that.
You are not only not observant.
I would say you're,
you're oblivious to your dense,
it's a big word.
You're,
you're just,
you're not aware.
You're not present stuff.
You're present person.
It's not about presence.
This is observant.
This is noticing things,
putting things together.
It's just very good at that.
You're just not very observant.
Uh,
yeah,
I think it would go you then Ellis than me though.
That'd be the order.
She's just,
I notice things about Ellis all the time.
Okay.
Now the one thing I can't do,
and you've brought this up before,
is sometimes I can't read people emotionally.
That's a big part of my observations.
But that's because of my upbringing.
Because I was raised by a mentally ill person and I don't always identify
feelings properly,
but I'm in therapy for it.
I'm with you all the time and you're,
and I'll say something and you're like,
I didn't notice that.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And then you go,
really?
Because I can't tell feelings and I've told it,
but that's because I'm in therapy for that.
That's part of being the observation champ.
I think that,
I know.
I think that's a fraction of the observation champs.
Here's what I'm good at.
An observation world.
No,
I'm serious.
I can listen to somebody talk and then I go,
Oh I know what their notice or issues or odd had a pair of shoes on that if we
have dinner with somebody and I'll be like,
did you notice how
he spoke to her,
his wife this way?
And that happened that dynamic.
And you be like,
Oh yeah,
no.
I'm like,
cause you're not observant all the time.
I'll be like,
oh my gosh,
did she know his child to thing is because of this and that I can,
I can break down what am I lying while my be able to say that.
You never say,
did you notice that he talked to it?
And then I go,
no,
I didn't know.
I always say yeah of course I did and this,
this and that.
So you're trying to describe the ringing at first cause I'm the observation
champ.
I bring it up.
You just agree with me.
I am definitely not stronger that I will give you,
I don't have a full beard and I am not strong or not,
but my vision and hearing is much better than yours as well.
And my teeth are wider.
Just like your sister.
I perfect teeth and perfect.
Yeah.
The vision is recent.
I used to have the sharpest vision in California
I have is deteriorated.
And how bad is it now,
Grandpa Cataracts Ag Canada?
It's bad.
No,
really?
it's not bad,
but it's I,
I mean I prefer to wear the glasses when I'm reading,
when I'm looking at mostly anything.
Yeah.
Your dad glasses,
everything is sharper and sharper and clearer.
Your blue blockers,
you got those on here's a review or was this on iTunes?
The Hay,
Hitler's thing.
We can't seem to shake as a meme.
So many people yelling at her and I have to talk about it when I opened for you.
Well,
that's right.
We made a list of things people were not allowed to do and number one was don't
shout,
Hey Hitler.
It'll interfere with the recording.
This says,
Hey Hitler's.
This is a review on iTunes,
which by the way,
of course I encourage anyone that listens to the show,
give us a five star well-written genes.
Tastic review only a five star.
Why?
Why go anything less?
Hey,
Hitler's,
you've got to get your life and listening to this podcast from high and tight
jeans.
Dad boners,
lots of Stan Ama and glass and they cover lots of ground like burnt,
burnt Chrysler's fat ass.
The podcasting world is the belt on the media world and this podcast is the
buckle that was powerful.
That is by Nolan from Winnipeg,
and a very observant review.
I might add,
I knew this was Canadian because it says Rogers is a screen grab of the Rogers,
um,
review that he's sending Roger's Roger's cellular.
I know that that's because they're in Canada.
Observant.
But you know,
I knew that,
I knew that idea that you're Canadian.
You didn't know I was born in Windsor,
Ontario.
Bright.
You're Canadian.
That's my fucking point.
Yes.
And I knew,
I knew Rogers.
I did it.
Just took me a second.
Gosh,
very soon we'll be joined by the Great Wheeler Walker Jr.
Uh,
the country music singer.
You're a huge performer.
I really liked his stuff.
I've really enjoyed it for a while.
Now a lot of people think you two are the same person.
It's,
I've gotten dozens of tweets.
Maybe hundreds.
Hmm.
About,
Hey,
I've never seen you two in the same room at the same time.
Blah,
blah blah.
It's so funny cause I get the same one with Claudia Schiffer.
People are like,
oh my God.
And then then you're like,
it's not me.
That's not me guys.
Yeah.
That was one of my early crushes shorter than me.
She's so pretty.
And just Kinda,
what made you think of her?
I was thinking of Heidi Klum,
but she has those little rabbit teeth.
She's got those real feminine front to Rabbit Teeth.
I wanted my veneers to look a little ride more rabbity but he did it.
He did it already on these,
well my two college roommates who you knew,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
we had a poster of her somewhere in her house thinking that kitchen Heidi of
Heidi decorum.
Yeah.
In,
in college.
She's still rocking,
man.
She looks great.
She looks amazing.
So the Germans,
let's see here,
Claudia Schiffer.
Claudia.
Let's see.
Why do you think those crowds age so well?
I don't know.
Here she is.
I think this set,
I tried to find a recent photo and she looks good.
Yeah.
How old is she?
By 50 by now.
Yeah.
Oh,
pause cause mom,
hey,
hey.
Hey.
We just,
we just jumped back in here.
We stopped.
Now we're rolling again as promised.
The great country music,
the legend is growing.
Wheeler Walker Jr.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you guys so much for having me.
I all the podcasts up til now has been fantastic.
I loved every second.
Okay.
It was,
um,
it was,
it's actually,
there's a lot of reasons we wanted to have you here.
One of them,
um,
as we were discussing a moment ago is I keep getting tweets and say,
I've never seen you and Wheeler Walker in the room at the same time.
Yeah.
I want to put that in people.
I've seen a lot of people,
um,
Photoshop your head onto mine on the album cover.
Yup.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah,
I've seen that too.
Which is,
by the way,
if we were the same guy,
you wouldn't need to photo.
It would just be you.
Right.
Good point.
I've heard,
I've heard that the like your,
that I'm you,
I've heard that Zach's,
you,
I've heard that Brent Hoffman.
Do you I've heard all these different guys.
Yeah.
For everyone.
Everyone thinks I'm some guy,
but I like to everyone they think I am.
I like to get,
you know,
be on their podcast.
Here we are talking by the way.
Okay.
It wouldn't take too much special effects to,
to um,
have you talking to yourself right now?
You know what they're going to point out now is that we're on different cameras.
Exactly.
So we're not the same fucking let's talk about,
let's talk.
Let's talk over each other.
No,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's like a ha.
I mean,
you've got to talk and talk.
Talk while I'm sorry.
Here we go.
Yes.
Different fucking guys.
But then they're going to say,
you just lay it on the IBM,
by the way.
Again,
the easiest thing to do.
Do you have really similar beard?
Yeah.
Color patterns as well.
Our length is pretty similar.
Oh
yeah.
By the way,
you're looking good.
Thanks buddy.
The,
the,
uh,
I did Brett's pod had a blast with red,
but I love this whole Tom and oh and burns a Chrysler.
Yeah,
I said Brett,
the bird thing is really cool because I love how you guys are really like,
it's real and you got,
and it's also healthy.
It's like,
yeah,
we lost a lot of weight and I mean obviously I lost more,
but yeah,
obviously you look fatter to you.
You just saw him recently.
You said Bert burnt.
How fat does he look burnt?
Um,
I think,
well I didn't really,
I didn't size them up too much before,
but I just walking and seeing you.
I would say you're like a healthy kind of the shape.
I mean,
I would if you'd said you were big before,
I wouldn't have know.
Like to me you just look like a kind of a skinny.
And how's that?
I mean,
but in relation to Tom,
how much bigger it is burnt look than Tom?
Well,
I don't wanna get myself in trouble,
but I am here right now.
So I would say,
I would say you look thinner that you definitely,
it's not even close to me.
I think.
I think he's just got to pick your brain.
I'll tell Ya.
One of the things I love on this as you do the those,
so you know,
I love that like the stern still like the old radio stuff.
It drops,
it's fun,
it's fun.
Um,
but yeah,
he,
I think he's got it maybe a bigger frame.
Like I feel like he's always going to kind of look like a bigger dude at Tito's
diet that he's on.
See,
the thing is he tries to fight the Tito's,
so he keeps her is Tequila Vodka drink.
He drinks his vodka,
but then he works out and he,
his body perfectly reflects it.
He looks like a guy that drinks a lot but then also runs.
Yeah,
you can't,
that's not special.
But I found this on the road,
which is,
I mean you guys get to fly in and you know,
stay in hotels and shit and people don't believe me,
but you really can't part like a traveling musician.
You can't party on the road,
it just doesn't work.
Like
the legends are that,
you know,
they're just fucking getting ripped every night.
It's like you meet it,
you know,
you get,
you could draw,
first of all,
we're always leaving and going on to the next town.
It's like
all my friends of course,
where you don't,
you're getting laid and every town it's like,
I meet a girl,
what am I going to do?
Take her on the bus and then take her with me to the next city.
Right.
Um,
I've done that.
But yeah,
what do you do is you don't,
uh,
you don't get late.
Yeah.
Right.
And I've just found out I've just,
and I hate to admit it,
it ruins my image,
but to,
uh,
I'm playing with it.
I can't play with a dog and talk at the same time.
It's cool.
Um,
sorry,
I,
Betsy,
come on my,
my problem is I can't have one beer.
It just,
I'd rather,
I'd much rather have no alcohol.
Then one day I just rather be sober than one beer,
cause one beer.
I want a second.
I don't want to say like I'm an alcoholic or something,
but
one beer to me and one shy,
just pointless.
It's just like a little taste of like the fun you can have.
But the problem about being sober is,
and you know,
like a music club is you're the only fucking sober dude in the whole place and
everyone's looking at you.
So you would rather just leave,
let me know.
I don't do anything
for me.
Uh,
having a beer isn't problem.
I like the one that I keep going down with his booze.
Like if I have a vodka drink or something.
Yeah.
Then I went two or three,
you know,
so I,
so I don't even start and I just go,
I don't like hanging out late in these loud bang.
I'm like an old guy.
Yeah.
I don't like,
yeah,
I'm the same way,
which is,
you know,
but you're the pussy king too.
Yeah.
How is that because of you're a persona?
I mean,
from what I,
I'm not,
no offense,
I'm not a huge country fan per se,
but we love your videos.
I love them because they're so provocative.
And you're out there and you kind of do come across as the pussy king.
He is the postseason.
Right.
If that's your thing.
Yeah.
I mean that's my thing was I wanted to kind of mark myself on this new record
is,
like I said before,
um,
you know,
Elvis was the king and Michael Jackson was the king of pop and like,
what am I,
you know,
there's only one left,
right?
Yeah.
The pussy king.
So I'll just,
once you,
once you start saying it,
you know,
like stern king of all media,
you just start saying,
I'll just start saying I'm the pussy king.
Yeah.
And it sticks.
Oh,
by the way,
I hear,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's see what you got.
Here's the new record.
Wow.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
this looks great.
And uh,
most important digital download inside,
look at the man sticker banned from Walmart,
target and best buy,
which was kind of bummed me out because you know,
our goal was to have the number one country album in the country,
but these country fans still fucking buy cds from like Walmart.
Sure.
So weird.
We the one here's some fucked up.
Yeah,
my album,
it's kind of hard to say no after.
I prefer phrase it like that.
But um,
we had the fifth bestselling country album in America last week.
That's crazy,
man.
Congratulations.
Thanks man.
But on the billboard country charts where number 10,
why is that?
Because they do this new fucking thing too to keep the Keith Urban's of the
world happy that they now incorporate like streaming and radio plays in it.
They keep that they,
they have in that in they like have a weird like algorithm and so like,
you know,
because to them,
and I guess it's true,
which is a Keith urban is more popular than me.
Right.
I don't see that,
but okay.
We'll thing but yeah.
Well I don't like let's,
let's uh,
roll through the run through this tracker or flooding rider's side and you do
decide ahead.
Good side a of this uh,
wheeler walker jr album,
all wheeler,
a side a has pussy king fucking around featuring Casey Walker,
ex wife.
Oh.
Uh,
the next track is puss in boots.
Next his finger up my butt and next is summers in Kentucky.
This is great.
And then side B,
we have a drunk sluts.
Amazing.
Ain't got enough dick to go around.
True.
If my dick is up,
why am I down?
Yeah.
Small town Saturday night pictures on my phone and then poon to round out.
This is amazing.
Fantastic.
Yeah,
this is great.
Oh yeah.
And you guys need,
you need Koozies,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
I think Koozies
or cozies koozies out there call you Muslim first album.
Cause I remember,
I remember Redneck Shit.
That was a,
that was a good video.
Then there's a,
yeah,
I remember this.
Can't fuck you off my mind.
Fuck you bitch eaten.
Posi kicking ass.
Fight and fucking and Fart and sit on my face.
Which one are you?
Queer.
It's going to suck my dick.
These are amazing.
Why?
The way I could be getting a lot of shit recently about how homophobic,
which I'm starting to get pissed about.
I'm like,
hmm.
Because the interviewers,
you know,
we'll do a lot of phone interviews,
you know which one he queer is going to suck my dick.
You know,
it's like homophobic.
I'm like,
no,
it's a homosexual.
Yeah,
you're asking them to suck your Dick.
It's like I'm the only fucking guy in country music talking about guys blowing
me getting so drunk that they do.
What I'm trying to do is obviously pissed off Nashville and I just really get
off on pissing people.
I want to ask you this,
cause I,
I didn't grow up really in the country,
but I did for a while live in Florida and it started to get,
you know,
it's just part of the culture started to get into it more.
And so actually I've been to,
I went to a Clint black concert,
I started to hear Hank Williams junior stuff like that was,
yeah,
I mean,
so I started to hear some of the music.
There's a lot of like nice bullshit,
especially in that call in the country culture.
You're one of the guys who's actually being like a little more like,
look,
it's not all fucking hugs and kisses man.
Like you're kind of talking talk some shit.
What it used to Piss me off is I,
cause I know a lot of these guys and then they'll press cut on the album and I'm
getting,
there'll be like,
man I got some fucking pussy last night.
But I'm like why are you saving the interesting shit for often like record that.
Yeah.
I mean I know you got to pay for your Butler and private planes and I know they
can't play that shit on the radio but it's like wouldn't it be nice if someone
cause the biggest genre in the world right now in America I'm sure by far is hip
hop because those go in and that stuff's hard.
X
cause I know like,
and it's all controvert and it's also like beefs and like wanting to fight now
you talk shit about some of the other guys even though,
yeah.
One Guy I'm that I talk shit about on the,
on the Song Poon I actually texted me the other day saying that he was honored
really?
So I thought that was cool.
He say who it is or no.
Yeah,
I'll say it.
It's got Jake Owen who is a big country star.
We went to high school in the same city.
No Way.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I always like it when,
you know,
and he said he was honored to yeah,
I mean fans,
they'll probably be pissed to know that like the guy even has my number,
but I've met him and he's a nice guy,
nice guy.
And like in my head,
you know,
be all I did.
Poon is just a song where I just kind of rip on all the,
and I literally,
I took the iTunes country charts from that day that was in the studio and I just
made them all raw rhyme,
you know,
so it was really
fucking talented at this man.
Can I ask you this though?
Because I,
I know like,
like we were just talking about how country stars,
you're expected be super nice
all the time and really accommodating to the fans.
Like Garth Brooks,
we follow him on social media.
Yeah,
I agree.
I don't think he's fantastic.
And if that gets me in trouble a lot too,
which is I fucking hate Garth Brooks.
I hate them too.
And I think his music and I hit his shin.
I could go on for an hour,
but I think he's part,
he's part of the reason country music.
Guts shitty.
Cause he was the first guy who kind of went pop.
Yeah.
And kind of took the country.
All this like any pander so much.
It's so fake.
I find him to be very this and genuine alerts.
What's that?
He'll,
he'll have on Twitter.
It's like,
it's like a flashing letter g g alert and then he'll,
you'll see him,
you'll see him in his fucking,
you know his mansion.
Like it's a g alert.
He's like,
I don't know if I can tell you guys,
it's like some top secret thing.
So you're like waiting for like,
you know this big news.
Like you know he's retiring or whatever it is.
And the g alert is that he's playing it.
Atlanta.
Yeah,
that's what I was just saying.
Cause I follow him on Instagram and he'll be like big news,
big surprise.
Swipe up to see it.
Just swipe up to see it.
And then you look and he's like,
I'm coming to Bose,
your city.
And you're like,
that's a surprise asshole.
You going to go there anyways.
It's not breaking news.
He's always in studio g studio.
You'll also refer to himself as when they're singing happy birthday.
He's like happy birthday to g said it to himself.
He calls himself,
Gee,
you're like,
dude,
you fucking,
and that's why I get pissed because that
truth because,
so he's,
I don't know this much about it.
I don't know the man,
but he was married and he doesn't do a Trish.
No,
he's married.
Married before.
But then Jerry,
before Dan does a duet with Trisha Yearwood,
now he's married to Trisha Yearwood.
So there's obviously a lot of shitty ain't singing about right.
That's the song we want to hear.
You know?
So that's why it gets,
it's like country music used to be about the truth and now it's just a bunch of
bullshit.
He's holding the phone.
Like when you sell tickets at any level,
you know you have sounds like it's cause people want to see you,
you have fans.
And I get it that like,
you know you're going to be,
obviously you're appreciative,
you want to be nice to your fans,
you want to say,
but the level of like it just seems disingenuous to be like,
Ha,
yeah,
I'm so,
I'm so overwhelmed and shout outs to every single person that follows him on
Twitter.
Like eat bro.
How can you be sorry I took something I do on podcasts a lot.
Interrupting people and I got to stop doing it.
No,
it's all good.
We're good.
We cut out that part.
I interrupted.
Christina was really embarrassing,
but,
well just say what?
I had a on Facebook.
I really wasn't sure if that's his dealer friend of mine said something that
just made all kinds of sense.
She said think of it more as a conversation.
Throw up in my mouth,
but I'm already finding out on my own so it's wiping the walls out between you
and me.
But I really was like,
that's like a gay video.
Yeah.
Like he's been trying to meet a dude on the Internet.
It is like a gay video.
Well I am.
It allows us to into each other's worlds where I can,
I guess in my case,
the hotel room,
when I think about things I want to post,
I want to post cool stuff,
slick stuff.
Most stuff I'm going to post is going to be raw stuff like this.
That's not wrong.
He's wearing his own merge so this is truly a conversation and I say let the
conversation begin.
So
contrived and there's no,
there's no natural to that.
Like your uncle trying out social media.
Yes,
exactly.
How it comes to Dolly Parton is famous for being super fan friendly.
Like I know that she lets people like sleep on her front lawn or I've heard
she's got Dollywood out outside of Nashville.
Do you let people do that to you?
Do you let people sleep out on your line?
Like how,
no,
no.
My thing is I have a,
this is why I think one popular in the country.
Why don't think what people dig about me is like if you look at my comments,
it's all kind of like the Tom and Burt thing.
It was just like it was a lot of people just,
you're fucking fat.
You fuck you.
So all my comments are just fans.
Like,
like,
oh,
not the tour.
And they're like,
you're not complaining my city.
Fuck you.
It's a bunch of people.
It's a bunch of,
all my fans told me to go fuck myself,
which I kind of appreciate,
which is so that I'll go,
I'll go onto Twitter and just be like this.
If you tweet me your city one more time.
I didn't come into it ever.
Wow.
And so,
because I'm just sick of them just being like,
they don't know how tours work.
It's not actual,
doesn't go through his Twitter and see where the fans want to play and then pick
dates.
I man,
I keep explaining to them that for,
at least for us,
like,
you know,
a promoter approaches me with a routing except actually don't,
and it's predetermined will me more than you.
I would bet because I got the band.
Yeah,
sure.
True.
And we're route,
he's like,
Toronto's not on the way between Nashville and Chattanooga.
We can't just go up to fucking pen.
They're like,
well,
add it bitch.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right.
There's a guy who,
I'm on my,
on my Facebook and tell me if you guys have found,
I've,
uh,
Facebook is by far the main gist.
I don't know why.
I think also those,
whatever his comments,
it sits there,
right?
Like Twitter kind of goes away.
I think maybe Facebook or people who haven't moved on to the other things and
they're still,
maybe they're just bitter that there,
but there's a guy who's just says his from English is,
has come to the UK,
you fucking loser.
And he's the first post.
He's the first guy to comment on everything I ever done.
Every time you post.
So it's just the UK,
you fucking losers like
plane tickets to England for fucking six dudes to get like,
do,
do I have an audience there?
I don't know.
I mean,
no one.
Have you gotten the,
uh,
well how much would it cost to book you say that you're supposed to be like a
hundred bucks.
Like people sometimes I'll get,
how much does it cost?
I'll get a lot of those.
Just like,
you know,
just like,
how much does it cost for you to play my bachelor party?
I'm like,
talk to my fucking Pete.
Well I don't know,
negotiate that.
And they're always,
you know,
like jokingly,
but it doesn't come off as it,
you know,
it's like you can fuck my sister while you're there.
Cool.
And I'm like,
all right,
cool.
Well then,
then I'll take two grand off the right.
Right.
Now this is probably
an obvious question,
but you fuck her on the back of this?
That was going to ask that.
Do you hook up?
No,
those were all um,
I wanted to,
I mean those were all Nashville models who,
um,
who fucking,
who were cool.
But um,
the insight,
well he could see better and yeah,
there's a poster that comes with a poster.
Oh,
that's cool.
Open it up.
There's a pussy king poster.
So we had these girls spelled WWE junior with their legs.
Wow.
And a couple of the girls complained that we showed their face.
They did complain.
Yeah.
But I think they only wanted to show there the crotch.
Sure.
Now,
do you get any pushback from the religious communities?
Because country music,
I mean we're talking that's a bible belt.
Yeah.
Well I mean I don't know that I think I'm doing as antivert you know,
is Pussy Anti Religion Nick?
I guess to some people.
I see what you're saying.
It's risky.
I mean,
yeah,
no I do get,
I mean if you were to go to my iTunes page it's like um oh wow.
It's five star.
It's wow,
it's a hundred and oh you got the big,
there's a big one.
If you guys want to take a look at that.
Yep.
See ww junior.
Yeah.
That's great.
It looks good.
And these girls were like,
I can,
you can see my face.
Yeah.
See I can see how that's offensive to women.
But to me it was sure it wasn't.
This is where I get in trouble cause to me I understand,
I understand how that's misogynistic just cause I'm just using them as letters.
But to me it's just like,
I thought it'd be cool to have them spell out my name.
I wasn't thinking like,
yeah.
Well,
you know what's interesting too is that in this day and age and feminism,
a lot of women are saying that this is empowerment,
right?
Like I,
I mean like a hot chick and don't call me a slut.
Like I can put my leg girl actually Instagram.
She's like her picture.
She's like,
I work.
She said I worked hard for this,
but it's really cool to see it.
And she was excited about it.
So I'm saying a lot of women see it.
They flip it a,
I don't know if I agree with it necessarily.
Maybe I just don't take anymore,
but I love vagina can read lyrics.
Yeah.
That's so cool.
Yeah,
I miss that.
It's kind of a bummer that I spent that much time on the hard work that no one's
going to see.
That's why I like to bring it.
No,
that's awesome man.
You know what I like to the attention to the pussy details.
If you look,
there's a lot lotta camel toe and then you can actually see like some vantage,
oh yeah.
At her lips right here.
You can see,
oh,
I didn't even fucking notice it,
but what about right here?
Look at the last one's lips.
The machine.
Hold on,
let me see.
Let me look at this.
Cool.
Yeah.
Look at the last two.
[inaudible] she just got drilled one girling one,
one of the girls,
her boob was popping out.
We had to fix it in Photoshop.
I thought,
oof,
you didn't,
um,
get it.
I don't know these,
these girls,
I don't know how they found five girls in Nashville who didn't know the fuck I
was,
but I've never seen five girls that less interested in me than those groups.
Really?
Yeah.
No,
they,
I mean,
how can that be though?
I don't know.
I was like,
what's it like being a country?
Like what's it like being a musician?
And I know you're going to be honest about it.
Well,
you're going to shows people are there to see you.
You're singing songs excited about,
I think you're meeting the girls out.
I mean,
they must go nuts.
Yeah.
Well,
it's Kinda what I sing about on the new record.
The new one's called old wheeler just because,
because I'm tall,
I feel like an old man and like,
why are you laughing?
Was it that was,
that was too obvious of a plug?
No,
it's such a,
you know,
oh,
I'm not,
the country world is,
you're from La,
grew up here.
I'm just,
I just,
uh,
for me it's funny because silly,
I've just been around the south so much and spent so much time.
I mean,
I lived in Florida and Carolina,
it's just like,
here's the old eight years old.
Yeah,
well there's,
there's,
I'm a huge Waylon Jennings fan and there was,
and there's a Waylon album called old Waylon,
so I'm just like,
oh,
playing off that,
all the,
the old,
um,
uh,
you know,
like really the album was just about my last year on the,
it was like,
okay.
And I was talking about it before.
I'm just,
I feel like I'm just getting gray in my beard and like,
you're meeting these girls who are snapchat,
Insta,
you know,
instagramming you naked pics on the DM.
And like,
I just don't know that like trying to figure out that like,
I feel like I'm a man at a time almost,
you know,
like I've,
I've considered myself,
although you wouldn't tell it by the pussy king poster,
like an old style southern gentlemen as much as the guy who thinks pussy king
can say that.
And then it's like you meet a girl and she'll just fucking text you or Twat,
you know,
it's like,
it's crazy.
So here it's like so weird for me.
Like,
cause I'm at the age of when seeing a naked girl on a playboy was the biggest
fucking deal you could think of.
I'm the same.
Yeah.
And now girls will send you like basically,
you know,
um,
okay.
I don't like ob Gyn fucking video.
They expect you to send your Dick Pic Tina
and I won't,
I won't do it.
Yeah,
why not?
You won't.
Cause I don't want it to,
it's just,
dude,
that has never happened to me.
No one's ever texted me,
um,
uh,
fuzzy pictures or anything.
But I always think that like if I were on the market these days,
one thing I would never do is text my dick.
Hell now.
Yeah.
Because all my buddies are like,
well you don't put your face in it then it's fine.
It's like that doesn't mean anything.
It doesn't,
if the,
if,
if a,
if a picture also I'm a grower not a show or as they say.
Sure.
Cause I know Ari was in here before last week and you said he had enormous
balls.
I also feel like I'm a grower with my balls to demand those grow.
Yeah.
I mean they don't actually grow,
but then you know,
you can find me on the wrong day and it'll look like a fucking baby.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm that too.
And then I like,
his boss was so dang,
but you've got really nice.
Awesome.
Those are exemplary.
Yeah.
But Dick was,
it's,
it's real.
Like last week I did a trim,
you know,
on the hair and it was just like,
it'd been a few days and you're like,
Whoa,
you're hot.
Looks different today.
Yeah.
But Da,
I noticed the operative thing is it looked different that day.
It's not like that every day.
Well,
I mean,
like my new thing is trying to,
getting ready for this tour we got coming up.
I've been exercising and running.
Like when I run my Dick's like this people can't stay on the podcast.
I'm holding two fingers very clear when I run my Dick fucking shrivels up.
Yeah.
So,
but then someone just wants a dick pic.
I don't want to sit there for 10 hours getting ready and jacking off and like to
look awesome.
Sure.
Yeah,
I did.
I also want to see,
I also want to see the tits in the post.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Do you have,
is there anyone that you're dating or anything?
I'm seeing,
I'm seeing somebody right now in,
in,
uh,
in Nashville who,
um,
do you know this podcast?
And it's been a problem of mine and I'm super hyper focused on right now because
the guide the other day texted tweeted me that I can't finish a complete,
I was on Rogan.
I didn't finish one complete sentence.
And now it's in my head.
So I'm no,
I got it.
I'm talking all over the place.
But yeah,
I was on this podcast called,
uh,
guys,
we fucked.
Do you know that pod?
Oh yeah,
I've heard of it.
It's popular.
It's very popular.
Yeah.
I did some promo in New York and they had,
they'd emailed me,
my people last year,
they wanted to use some of my songs and their podcasts.
I'm like,
yeah,
sounds good.
Like it next time you're in New York,
just come and do the podcast.
And um,
it's just this real,
it's a really cool podcast with these two girls.
Just talk like kind of nasty.
Yeah.
You know,
sex,
talk about their real experiences or what's yeah.
Which it's almost like,
you know what guys do all the time,
but they do it and it's really cool.
It's really cool.
I think empowering to me,
that to me that's empowering.
Talking about,
you know,
they call it the anti slut shaming podcast.
And I went on it and I told a bunch of details
and my lady friend was none too happy about that.
Sure.
And so,
so to keep her from it,
I said I'd refer to as a girl.
I used to see,
oh boy.
So which I thought was helping the situation,
right?
Because I was like an old story.
Yes.
So,
so if people saw me out in Nashville with this girl,
they wouldn't be like,
oh,
I heard you talking about the sock stories with her.
I thought it was protecting her and it actually was a double whammy when number
one,
I was talking explicit shit about her.
Yeah.
And also too,
I was saying on a podcast that I wasn't seeing her anymore.
Right.
So it fun.
So I got to,
I'm trying to watch what I say now on on podcasts.
No,
that's all good,
man.
Yeah,
I mean I think you did it.
You were,
you had the good intention.
Well also too,
you get those,
you forget how big these fucking podcast like,
yeah.
The reason I say,
and not to be rude to her,
but I was just like,
there's no way she's ever been.
I mean,
there's 8 million podcasts.
Why would you listen to this one?
That makes sense.
Then she did and she's smart and she likes hearing
what class you were,
you were on a podcast with like either,
I don't know what those girls look like,
but they're probably like two hot chicks,
right?
Yeah.
Not Banging dudes.
So of course your lady's going to be like,
um,
what is it you were saying you would listen to if I was oh yeah,
I'd be like,
first of all,
you're not doing that show.
And then secondly,
what you talking about with those sleds?
Yeah,
I'm sure they're lovely.
I don't even know them or they kind of mix.
Uh,
I think so.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
you should.
Um,
I don't want to,
I'd rather plug my album in there.
Yeah.
Play some of his new album.
Is that allowed?
You're
a,
if you want to,
here's one thing,
which is why I'm,
who I am is my independence,
which is whether you want to play it or not.
Just to let you know,
I owned my masters,
I owned my song,
you know,
like
it was an important thing for me to own everything.
So like,
yeah,
if some kind of shitty come,
you know,
Burger company wants to use my,
Carl's junior wants to play,
fuck you bitch while still needs a burger.
I can say no.
Like I literally own it like I can,
and I've had this before too.
Friends want to use it for a thing here or there and I just say go,
you know,
I know they don't have money.
If it's just like a podcast,
I'll just say two,
I won't get flagged if we play it on something,
she might get what's happened.
And that happened with Rogan before,
which is it gets flagged because of the distribution company.
But the flagging,
it doesn't matter that it's like,
because it comes back around to me and I say,
Oh let it go.
Yeah.
Great.
Um,
yeah,
I mean you have a new album out.
It's doing really well and the tour is going to kick off soon.
Yeah.
Well when will this come out?
It just comes out a day or two.
Yeah.
Okay.
So yeah,
probably a couple of weeks from now.
And I meant to text my manager to see what markets,
it's weird to f is there a site to buy tickets though?
Yeah,
my website,
which is Wheeler Walker Jr com and then pride backslash tour,
I think for the tour dates had a fine,
well they don't really,
cause they tweet me.
Where are you playing on this tour?
No,
that Shit's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I also get this,
um,
you know,
we'll plug that I'm in whatever,
going to Philly.
Then the tweet comes in,
are you in Philly now?
And I go,
yeah.
Shows tonight.
Yes.
Where?
I'm like,
Dude,
oh dude,
I'll set that.
It's like who,
what times open or go on.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's like,
you know what time you go on.
It's like,
I don't want it.
Not only do I not like how fucking lazy are you would like also,
I want you to see though
Google it.
Yeah.
And I know it's like,
just fucking,
come on,
look it up.
Now,
is there a real problem with you and and Georgia,
Florida Line,
Florida,
Georgia line?
I don't know the name.
I went,
I went after country group.
Here's the big,
they're massive.
Massive for someone.
I like having Christina here because she's someone who doesn't know this world,
so I can just explain it really simply.
Country Music used to be really fucking good and then it became
white people pop music,
like the stuff that comes if,
if like if after this,
like if Tom Played You Florida,
Georgia line,
you would and told you that was a hit country song,
your mind would be fucking blown because it was like it doesn't,
it's just,
it's new kids on the block.
Right.
And that's like the number,
that'd be like a number one country song.
Yeah,
it's,
it's just,
it's just pop crap,
which is,
it's kind of,
someone described the other day I was,
because people are trying to do,
it's a big argument,
which I don't really give that much of a shit about,
but you know,
what is country music these days?
And one of my friends,
okay,
her definition,
which a friend told her it was just country music is now defined as just
whatever white people are listening to.
[inaudible] not a bad,
it's not a bad description,
which is they're actually taking,
cause you know the old cliche about like whatever's cool in New York or la is
like gets to the south,
you know,
10 years later.
Right.
And it's true in music too,
which is like a lot of these beats and all those sound like it's Kinda like hip
hop from like 10 or 15 years ago.
Yeah.
It's like,
it sounds like fucking MC hammer or milli Vanilli yeah.
Yeah.
And it's fucking garbage.
And so my thing was I'm going to play real country music and since I'm playing
real country,
no one's going to fucking play it anyway cause they the one real country.
So I may as well.
I might as well not censor my,
because everyone would want to sing dirty if they could hate the most and
country music right now.
Who's the worst?
It's not really hate.
But um,
the,
the worst artists are definitely Florida,
Georgia line.
There's just guys,
same hunt who um,
and I'm trying to get my words to good cause all these people,
by the way,
now that I'm on the charts,
they,
they don't come after me.
But there,
there are people being,
you know,
can you knock it off a little?
Really?
They'll,
they'll reach out about that.
I've had,
I've had a couple of people reach out.
None,
none of either these guys,
but I've met these people.
The problem is not a problem but they're not bad people.
You know,
you meet him there like,
like you probably have friends who are comics who are like super nice guys who
aren't fucking funny.
Right,
right,
right.
But what do you do?
But yeah,
there are like it was just here last week.
Oh yeah.
We know.
But I'm doing his thing cause I'm in town for the next week.
I'm doing a the punch drunk thing tomorrow.
What's that?
Sports podcast.
Yeah,
that'll be,
that'll be fun.
That'll be fun.
Yeah.
And I'm doing to kill Tony Tonight.
That's really fun.
Is that fun?
Really Fun.
Yeah.
I've really found,
and that's why I love doing this stuff is because radio is pretty much banned
me.
And it's almost like a big fuck you to just fuck you fuck this mainstream with
a,
with a lot of the podcasts like we're talking about,
you're reaching more people to,
oh that's a thing too is I um,
and I,
and we talked about it before,
actually talked about it on Rogan,
which is,
and I've got the numbers to prove it.
Rogan's bigger than SNL if you're a musician for sure.
Like people don't understand like I'm going through the back door,
you know,
like yeah.
Cause when we put it out I was like fuck,
you know,
I can't get on the radio and then we won't even have me on the radio to
interview me without even play or even play or bleep it out.
You just built up just band.
Nobody even listens to terrestrial radio anymore.
Some do,
some all market,
some genres still had country is a country has a business.
There's a lot of people who don't,
who have cassette players in their cars.
It's true and implicit to radio and go to Walmart to buy cds.
Do you have any relationship with Toby Keith?
Uh,
no,
but I heard a rumor that he wanted me to open a show,
but I didn't.
I don't know if they ever panned out.
Really.
That'd be,
I mean,
I know it didn't pan out,
but I don't know if you imagine like him,
I'm sure his draw is unreal.
Yeah.
For you to go out there and do the pussy king,
I'd love to do it,
but yeah,
I think that's the other problem too is we couldn't really,
we couldn't really tour until I could headline because no one would have me.
No,
I can open for anybody because a lot of these countries,
you know like Toby,
Toby,
Keith,
it'd be parents and the two little girls or something.
I can't sing that doesn't Toby Keith have a rib place.
He has a restaurant.
Yeah.
Toby Keith.
I love these ribs or something.
Red,
white and blue.
I love these ribs and yet here he had an album called shock and y'all
Florida,
Georgia line just opened up a restaurant in Nashville,
which is,
I can only imagine.
I mean if their foods,
if they're foods twice as good as their music,
it's still shit.
Now will you be opening a pussy king restaurant and we're doing it.
We're doing a pussy,
pussy cat.
I actually just reached out to the two of these guys who make pocket pussies to
see if they wanted to make a special wheel.
Can I pull up the video that you can play?
That video is really great.
You're going to do a pocket pussy,
do you?
But nothing for a restaurant or food.
No,
I ain't got that kind of cash yet.
I got it right.
I mean once I can.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
we're doing the whole,
we're doing the vivo one.
Is that the one to play?
Yeah.
Which,
which,
which song?
Which one you're talking about posted king.
Yeah.
Is that the is,
hold on,
I'll show you.
Is it better to play this one?
Oh,
you're vivo channel.
Yeah,
that's the real one.
That's the real one.
Okay.
You're really kind of an outlaw
country music.
I mean this video is great.
The song is great.
I love
some of the vocals are really,
might be audio show him
fishing in Austin is
when one watches one pounds a y
legs.
Oh performing.
Thanks.
Anal doesn't count.
Dick still taste.
All the pain is drop down
so you could get into this kind of,
I like it.
It's honest.
It's real kind of like bullshit.
I my my dark when I was on that when I was on the road,
he got girls ask me all the time,
I'm like,
maybe I am the pussy king.
You know?
Do you get a lot of push back off from the women's groups and stuff?
If we not,
is her mouth to the smart Limon to kind of get it and the fun of it.
But yes,
I do
mean
next year when his daughter gonna turn.
I bet your show is fun,
man.
That I'd like to see what's live.
Yeah,
a lot of towns.
That's awesome.
Place to work.
My good guy.
He did this video,
his pants and his name is Cameron Crowe,
but not that one.
Are you being serious?
Yeah.
It doesn't have an ego.
It's a great video.
And he did a great job with that.
Really great graphics.
Yeah.
It's like Rogan.
There
is a great singer like that.
Yes.
Wow.
The best way I would describe it as good.
It just feels like a throwback to real country music.
Well that,
well this one is this song especially,
which is,
you know,
I was here all that,
like I said,
kind of shitty white boy rap on the radio.
I'm,
yeah,
let's do the old kind of like Jerry Reed kind of country funk shit.
So you grew up,
did you grow up in Nashville?
I grew up in Kentucky and my thought,
my mom and all my family's from that.
So it's really strange right now,
which is,
I don't know if you guys know,
but Nashville is like the hit the city in the world and it's cool.
My last,
you know,
as a kid,
I knew it as a kid when it was like a fucking ghost town.
Yeah.
And now the rent's fucking crazy.
It's like,
since I've been a kid,
it's become this like super hip place and I can barely afford to live there.
I got a buddy there.
Um,
I can't believe,
I'm sorry,
I'm still blown away that you're not getting laid every night
at the shows me.
Why do I do okay?
I do.
Okay.
Secret
is,
I was talking to a buddy of mine the other day just about this as secret as to
party between tours.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So going around Nash,
I mean,
it's easier.
I can meet girls in Nashville going out to bars and stuff.
Right.
Why meet one and fucking Boise when it's just some random girl who was like,
you got to get through that tour,
which is also work.
You've got to have stamina to get through it.
Yeah.
I need more stand in my,
because of the last tour I um,
I went a little too crazy and not a joke.
I put myself in the hospital for real.
Yeah.
At the tour ended and I was,
and what happened was I am the tour,
I ended up in La and it's kind of a secret,
but I don't really give a shit anymore,
which is why we're doing a TV special.
And I'm torn it in La.
I had some meetings about this wheeler Walker Jr TV special and we were in this
big fancy Hollywood building or wherever it was,
Beverly hills.
And the tour ended the night before and I barfed on myself in the fucking
meeting with all these suits there and almost lost the show because I think they
thought I was on heroin or drugs or some shit.
But I was really just exhausted from tea.
I went too hard on the tour.
I'm with you,
dude.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
it was,
cause it was,
it was really,
so what happened was I called,
um,
I called my family and just like,
you know,
I'm sick,
so give me,
leave me alone for a couple of days.
And I went back to the hotel and 48 hours later,
or no,
I think it was 24 hours later,
I heard banging on the door and they were about to break down the door.
They had the tour manager come over and they hadn't heard from me for what
happened was I passed out,
I was so exhausted from the tour and I was so sick.
I didn't wake up for 24 hours.
They were about to bust down the hotel,
you know,
had to,
I had the whole thing locked.
They were about to bust on the hotel room door and then they had to take me to
the hospital and like put the Ivs in and all my street
when I,
I haven't had it like that.
But I would say even without partying,
cause I'm not a big party guy.
I've had a tour where,
you know,
it was a different city every night for five nights a week,
three weeks in a row,
one week off,
then back to three weeks in a row.
And at the end of like the third month of that I just fully broke down and got
like really sick,
you know?
Yeah.
And I think too,
I was from my friends are talking about,
I think there was,
although I don't want to admit it was probably a mental uh sure.
You know,
part of it too,
which was just like emotionally and physically,
just everything was just drained.
And then,
you know,
like they filled me up with,
with fluids at the,
at the emergency room and I guess it helped,
but I still,
I mean it took two weeks for me to really kind of be yet touring actually
the most people and I was one of these people whenever you heard about like big
stars.
Yeah.
Sound like you're like,
you're like,
that sounds like bullshit.
Like they suffering from exhaustion and then if you actually tour,
it's the one thing that when you,
you see it on the news with somebody,
you start to have empathy for it.
You're like,
oh yeah,
that person,
I believe that.
Like they're actually really good.
And you hear about those fuckers.
Like,
let's say Garth Brooks for example,
who I heard,
and I can't say this for a fact,
but I'm pretty sure I'm right.
Someone told me,
you know,
he has that Vegas residency and he wants to,
but he wants to sleep at home.
So he walks out of the bay,
the GIG and gets on a private plane and they fly him back to wherever you live
in Oklahoma.
He doesn't sleep.
He has,
there's,
there's artists at that level now,
you know,
which fair to say?
I'm pretty fucking far from that.
Who Do tours where they,
they just sleep,
sleep in their own place every night they walk,
they walk out the back of the arena.
If you're that rich.
Yeah,
why not?
So I felt it had that thing where,
so he,
he got an offer,
he was in an interview saying that he got an offer to do a private gig in The
Bahamas,
but for like super wealthy people,
but for like 10 people.
And so the,
the,
you know,
what he required was,
obviously extraordinary amount of money,
he would not mingle pre show.
That's imperative.
Flew in the end.
He's like,
it has to be set up like this.
They introduced him,
he came in,
he did the show,
walked out and flew back from The Bahamas to lower for 10 people.
Yeah.
But it was for,
you know,
probably seven figures.
I mean that's the only,
sometimes those are the like I'll get it like a,
you know,
a bachelor party or somewhere private party that'll pay for the rest of the
tour.
Touring is so fucking,
it's with a band.
It's,
I bet you at a bachelor party would probably be a really fun,
yeah,
you'd be a great act,
but not to act to diva.
But we do have to have my people tell him like,
you know,
he ain't going to the titty bar with you afterwards.
You know what?
I don't want to do that.
I want to hang out with you all night.
Yeah.
You're buying my friendship.
Right.
Um,
cause that's too expensive.
Sex M uh,
we live inside studio g were,
where's the G Douche bag?
She's welcome to insight studio g where music is first here and he's acting like
he's not a billion.
Really cool.
Right.
Because that's what I was going to say before was,
so I had to,
when I had the first record,
I was kind of shopping around.
I did meet at,
at a capitol records.
It didn't take the w nothing against them,
but it,
it was,
it would have been the completely wrong place to do it because they don't know
how to market it or they,
you know,
their thing is to go to radio,
go to MTV,
all the Shit I couldn't do.
But it was nice to know to meet with me.
Nice dudes.
But I was in the lobby and the lobby,
they had
all,
every capital album that had gone,
you know what diamond is?
Diamond know platinum is million copies.
Right.
And diamond,
they have this new thing called diamond,
which is 10 million,
10 million.
So they had,
they had,
they had a plaque of every diamond album the capital ever put out,
which was,
it literally was,
it was like dark side of the moon.
And then every Beatles album and pretty much every Garth Brooks album.
Wow.
And then you think about the Beatles,
which is like,
you know,
back in the old days and there's four of them.
It's Garth Brooks,
just fucking ham.
And he had like fucking 10 of these.
That's crazy man.
I mean this guy has got more,
he played uh,
uh Rupp arena,
which is a big arena where my hometown,
that's 23,000.
He played two sold out shows there in one night.
Jesus.
Okay.
Earlier this year I did a Gig in Edmonton at a theater.
I was there the same week as him and he was doing wherever the Oilers play,
which is about 20,000.
He did nine,
oh my God.
Out,
I think its Rogers arena or something.
Pretty good.
That's the thing is that if you're that popular,
you've got to be so detached from is,
I think he's proving here that he's detached.
Yeah.
But he's trying,
that's the thing.
He's trying to show you that I'm not,
but he's also,
don't forget he's,
he's actually not,
I mean he still sells tickets like a motherfucker,
but he's also not adapting well with this new world.
You know,
Shit's not on iTunes.
It's not on Spotify.
Why he it?
He thinks it's a rip off.
And he,
he the rip off to them?
To him?
No,
him.
Oh,
oh.
I mean,
I don't know what the specific things are.
He's like,
he wanted an iTunes is what I heard was he wanted iTunes to not have the ability
he's,
he's like their albums or pieces of work.
Yeah,
you can't,
I don't want you to be able to sell single tracks.
Oh,
he's,
oh,
I do just like,
couldn't he do like album only sales then they,
they were like,
that's not what what we do here and yeah,
and his,
his,
I think he was just like,
well,
I'm Garth Brooks.
I make the rules in like,
yeah,
we're,
we're apple.
No,
no,
you don't.
Or how does he sell his albums?
And he actually tried to a,
this is how dumb he is.
He,
he um,
he,
he had built a website where he actually,
I'm making the war the term up,
but like instead of mp3s,
they were like Garth p threes.
But I'm,
but I'm making that up.
But Two p threes.
Yeah.
But it was GP yet he invented his format.
What?
Andy had his fans by it just directly from him.
Wow.
But he just signed,
you can buy his music digitally and I'll give them a nice plug.
He just signed an exclusive e f the first co he's now you can buy his albums
digitally at Amazon.
Oh,
they let them do it.
So now if you,
a lot of these videos here,
these stupid shit,
there's,
you see Amazon logos behind him because he got his,
cause he's only,
he finally like,
we're talking about a guy who got into the digital music world like three
months.
Yeah.
It literally social media.
I got and his new albums don't sell.
Huh?
Did he?
He was so angry.
That's close down me happy birthday to you.
Yeah.
You see that by the way.
Okay.
Let me look at the rage on his face.
Will knock happens.
Look at the rage.
And he's like,
is that supposed to happen?
Looking at them?
I got,
it's like knocking on the fucking door when I'm doing my,
and he probably watched it.
Still funny updates.
Is that supposed to happen?
Yes,
thank God,
thank God.
Nothing unexpected happen.
And for that g alert,
so yeah,
it was good cause like my,
the arena and my hometown is 23,000.
That's crazy.
All Bet.
I'll bet he was just like,
I bet it's whoever runs this shit.
It's just like 23,000,
like that's not even worth our time.
So he's like,
we'll do to,
cause some friends of mine when they said like the,
you know,
the stairway,
it's like he's got pet.
It was like congested because people leaving and coming in and he does a long
show too.
He's like,
the shows were 23,000 people,
two sold out shows,
one,
six 31,
nine 30.
Wow.
Jeez.
He did that video.
I don't think we have the drop where he's talking about.
Um,
he's like,
you know,
people email me that like during the show they'll be looking at the,
the,
the guy doing the lighting and they're like,
oh God.
It's like,
yeah man.
I mean that's what people,
they get into everybody.
They're not just,
they're firm and they're looking at the lighting guy and they're living at that
session.
He's trying to give credit to the lighting guy,
the grip guy.
They get these,
these are the ones that are doing the work.
I'm not doing the work,
I'm just the front
man birthday birthday.
So give him,
give them the money.
Right.
Chop it up,
right?
Yeah.
That's like,
yeah,
he's the one really doing the work.
The lighting man gets 30% know about
man right here.
Are you a fan of,
uh,
so what is your regimen now?
What exactly?
Test?
Not really.
I mean,
I don't dislike him.
He actually had a shirt on,
but I think that would be,
that's kind of gaze and like,
can I just get a hit this year,
this past year book written by a friend of mine does a great song to me.
That's so weird.
That was,
that was weird.
Yeah.
A friend of mine who I'm from playing a Gig with next week in Nashville,
a charity Gig,
he just opened up for him and uh,
I saw a video of it on instinct.
I mean,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's like,
don't you feel like country music nowadays almost underground music,
like the big stars aren't like the real world.
Big Stars like,
yeah,
but they fill,
they fucking pack arenas wherever they can,
like arena,
but like these guys wouldn't hold a candle fame wise to like a Kim Kardashian or
Kanye or any of these guys.
You know?
It's like they're not in yet.
Our Lady Gaga,
but they probably do as much right
business do they like,
I'll bet Garth Brooks is 20 literally 20 to 50 times bigger than lady Gaga.
Lady Gaga is in the news.
All right.
Yeah.
Well they're white.
His teeth are those look good.
Like if Garth Brooks is said all those diamond records,
I mean Gaga,
Katy Perry,
they've never had a no.
Even half that,
by the way,
nobody would ever allow what Katie correct.
If it had been the reverse,
if it had been like a guy,
just a touch.
I just,
can I just touch you?
Super Weird.
Tits look great.
You mind if I just did?
Wow.
They are.
They're real natural.
Yeah.
Super Weird.
That is,
but you're right.
It is something that Garth didn't adapt to this digital era.
I mean,
lady,
well I knew his new album's called man versus machine help versus right there an
adversarial attitude towards social media.
Yeah,
the machine.
What's the machine?
Right.
Because Lady Lady gap swaps is on Twitter and she's got gazillion,
you know,
millennials and Garth didn't get that audience I guess.
Huh.
But not to be,
not to be on iTunes.
You're not in the game.
Crazy not to be on Spotify.
Yeah.
Kids nowadays just make a Spotify playlist.
Right.
But yet to me,
he was kind of the turning point when everything turned,
because remember they used to hook his fat ass up to those fucking wires and he
would fly through the arena because that's not like Willie Nelson never did that
shit.
You know,
he tried to turn it into Bon Jovi.
Yeah.
So to me he was the first one to kind of turn country into self sacrifice.
So do you think the Garth Brooks is responsible for the sucker fication of
country music?
He was the beginning of it.
I mean,
yeah,
in a weird way.
I mean now compared to the shit out there now,
he sounds like fucking woody Guthrie,
you know,
you sounds like,
he sounds old school compared to what's out there now.
But at the time I just remember being in high school in Kentucky and like you'd
walk into a room and the teachers and the kids together,
we're in friends in low places.
Like it was like glee or something like that.
She was the biggest fucking song in the world.
And I remember just hating those fucking songs.
Yeah.
And they just sign it because he come to town and you don't want to listen to
what your parents listened to.
My parents would go to the show and like aunts and uncles and like,
it was like more for parents.
I know you guys are lame.
It was like a little kid.
I don't want to go like that.
I was like little kids and parents were in Kentucky.
Was it?
Lexington?
Lexington,
which is a big city.
You know where I'm from.
Yeah.
Um,
this is a,
by the way,
a super example,
very clear of the dynamic that exists within like the country,
at least the popular country culture is this interviewer.
And you'll see like,
Mary,
you are so beautiful.
Oh my God,
am I fell at Oklahoma Girl?
Yeah,
I wasn't,
I was your age not too long ago.
Now people sit down.
Here's a question my Stuart Stuart's put on Sunday,
not to interrupt,
but like,
look at that role of woman.
Why is she the star?
You know,
what is her voice better than the rest of those girls?
Probably not,
but yeah,
you can tell by the faces which one gets to be the star,
right?
Right,
yeah,
sure can.
Yeah.
Wait,
so who's this?
Who's this blonde?
Tall.
This is Carrie Underwood here.
I don't know that other girl.
And then this one right here,
I don't know.
But obviously everybody knows her fry it a reality show.
Just tell me to take off my shorts,
shorts,
put on some normal jeans and get off the head of the car.
I mean,
that's just,
yeah,
that's like slang.
I don't know what is that.
English is going to go in and see if there's of these people's faces.
Oh my gosh,
no perfect.
Just like my girls from Oklahoma,
this is an arena.
And People Watch that as entertainment now.
Humana from there she was like,
all right y'all.
And now here's a wheeler walker jr with gray hair up my butt.
That's what I'm really trying.
That's what I'm getting on.
The charge is a big deal for me cause I like be like,
I like knowing that someone like that it's manager had to get up at that next on
Monday morning and go,
you're number 11.
Yeah,
well I'm not in the top 10 who's number 10
and they're like,
don't,
don't tell her,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fuck.
You know.
So,
but I will say in fairness,
there's a lot of kind of big country artists who are fans and who would piss me
off too is like they call me or get to my good to me through their people and
you know,
fucking cause they want to look cool.
I love what you're doing.
So fucking bad ass.
And I'm like,
put on a fucking tee shirt,
tweet about it.
You know,
don't keep it to your fucking self.
You know?
It's like,
so you're cool thing to like say you're a fan of mine.
Right,
right.
But they don't want to lose scared.
They're scared to mention it.
That's what the thing is.
I think that that fear exists more in country,
like other genres of music.
They wouldn't be a remember to that.
Uh,
and if you haven't seen it,
I always recommend this movie,
this documentary,
the Dixie chicks.
I forget the title of the documentary about how they,
when they got banned from country music,
like they're still gone from country music.
People hate them still.
Yeah.
That's great.
Because they spoke out against the war,
the war,
which by the way,
right.
But is it Bush?
Yeah.
But I don't,
I don't,
I don't want to get political,
but that's what Trump ran on is,
which is what they said.
Wow.
You know?
So what they're saying is what everyone does now agrees with and they still
can't come back.
You brought your guitar.
Would you mind playing a song?
Yeah.
Okay.
Why don't I play,
here's what I want to play because,
well,
I want to preface it by saying something.
I don't know if you guys knew this.
It's kind of a big deal.
I blew up on black Twitter two weeks ago.
You know what that is?
Black Twitter.
Yeah,
sure.
So I have a song from the first record called fuck you bitch.
Yeah.
And somebody from the people who make,
my record's called me up like,
what's going on with your first rep because of the new one just came out like,
why is your first record selling a bunch?
And I have no,
I looked and they go,
you blew it.
You blew up on black Twitter.
Wow.
And I didn't know what that was.
It apparently it's kind of like just the three.
The rest of the world is like,
shit gets hot in the like a black Instagram,
black Twitter first and it of black Instagram too.
Well,
I mean if it's,
you know,
it's not separate,
but it's within the,
this one dude,
his name was de Quan or something.
Yeah.
He's a big mean guy.
He posted my post to fuck you bitch.
And it got like 200 million views.
Wow.
Crazy.
And it was in the mind,
that song from the first record went back up the charts after while my new one
was coming out.
So I want to,
I know you can the watchers and all those guys.
I know you guys got a lot of black fans.
Yeah.
Go,
go for it man.
We're going to get a real taste right now.
Awesome.
Yeah.
What's up?
What's this?
What are we seeing?
Oh Wow.
That's gorgeous.
Someone made that for you?
Gibson.
Getting them gives me free guitar.
No.
Ah Wow.
And at what point does that happen though?
I think when my first album was in the top 10.
So a Gibson rep called suffering injuries,
we should,
so some,
someone a Gibson.
Wow.
I want to take a picture of you with your Gibson and his,
he has his name Tom Together.
Um,
let me ask you also before you play it,
what,
um,
so you know,
you're in Kentucky or in Nashville growing up,
uh,
are you always playing music then?
Growing up,
I was always playing music and then,
um,
so I was always playing and I always,
and I was more of a rock guy to be honest.
Yeah.
Um,
and I've got my headphones also let me know if I'm not close enough to the mind,
but for some reason when I played and sang,
I could always sing better.
No,
sounded more natural.
When I played country,
I couldn't,
I didn't have a good rock voice and I didn't really,
I wasn't like a killer,
like guitar.
I had nothing to offer really for,
you know,
like I love Zeppelin,
but there's nothing like I can't be Robert Plant,
I can't beat Jimmy page,
but I could kind of hold mine.
I could hold my own with in the country stuff.
But yeah,
they called me,
they said if you only play Gibson guitars,
we'll give you all the gifts as you want.
One.
I go,
that sounds like a fucking cause.
Gibson,
it gives it a,
Martin are the two best acoustics.
It's like Mercedes,
BMW,
it doesn't matter where you already,
so you already had some Gibsons though.
You were playing Gibson.
I was actually playing a Martin at the time and I go,
I told him I had a Martin there was just like keeping your house and don't play
it in public and we're fine.
I said,
it didn't make me bash it or throw it away.
Yeah.
You know?
It was really,
it was really cool of him and I'm so you're going to play time.
I get this thing out.
I'm still amazed that they made this amazing.
It's beautiful.
They're going to play.
Fuck you bitch.
Yeah.
Just cause it's really easy to play on on acoustic.
Okay,
sure.
I'm in tune.
Yeah.
How's the sound?
That's a Gibson sound
fucking lineage.
You broke my heart.
Fuck your friends tearing us apart.
Love your dog will be never comes home.
You leave it
alone.
Now you're
jerking off pictures.
All this full.
A swap on your fleece.
Just skirt.
Fuck you.
Bitch broke my heart.
Fuck your friend Taryn News.
Par.
Your dog never comes home.
You.
You be windup.
Hello.
Word is out.
You found so long.
Well,
a home does it for you,
but if not,
fuck,
fuck
France.
Tyranny Park.
Hope he never comes home.
Hello.
Hope Yolanda.
Hi.
That's fantastic.
Great man.
That was beautiful.
Thank you for doing that.
Okay.
I loved it.
But you know what I love it does Harken back to,
I mean at least what little I know of country music,
kind of the Oji themes of like hope your fucking dog dies.
You know,
it's the heartbreak and drama.
Appreciate they,
cause that was kind of my whole point,
which is,
you know,
you could dumped by a girl,
um,
and you know,
if,
whether it's your fault or not,
let's just assume it was my fault.
He,
when she dumped me like I was being an Asshole,
you're under your first dog.
It's like,
Oh fuck you bitch.
You know,
it's like in your head,
it's not like women are bitches,
you know,
it's just like,
yeah,
fuck you for hurting me.
It's almost empowering in a weird way.
Like you had that much control over me,
you know,
like fuck you bitch.
Okay.
Cause I grew up,
you know,
with country.
But I also grew
up,
lets you know that hip hop world,
of course it's out there.
It's like,
why can't we talk openly in an uncensored about if I,
if I'm feeling that a million other people gotta be feeling.
So just why,
why sensor it when,
when I got to ask this,
we haven't yet,
cause you mentioned your family multiple times and we're looking at these
posters and he tracks and everything.
What do they think of this music?
Like what does your mom think of wheels turning?
Because it had all this fun on podcasts.
I started doing a podcast and it's,
we're still working out the kinks but it's,
it's up on iTunes and shit.
But I didn't have interviewed my dad on it and um,
they don't love it.
I did play a,
they came to a couple of gay,
they came to a couple of Nashville gigs and I'm,
dude,
I'll tell you what's fucking weird.
It's a whole big audience
singing along to fuck you bitch while your mom.
Cause I got my shades on,
you know,
and I could see my,
I'm watch all,
I'm watching his,
my,
I'm pulling it down like she can't,
so she can't tell and I'm just watching my momma,
you know.
And she's,
she's got a weird,
I've never seen her,
she's never made this face before since,
but the face was,
it was a weird mix of like,
I'm proud that,
you know,
there's a whole giant room of people singing along mixed with what did I do
wrong to make him sing like this?
And she's,
she's watching them go to the merchant booth by and tee shirts and shit.
So it's,
yeah,
I've never seen so much.
I'm proud and discuss it at the same time.
Like she got both expressions on her face really well.
Go to a thousand ranch dotcom and buy some tickets to see those big mushy
purples as my dad login Christina's website.
But don't you think though,
you know,
once your mom sees how successful you are that you can be like,
mom,
this is the house that fuck you bitch belt.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
he ain't build a house yet and that,
um,
and once I buy them a house may be better.
But yeah,
I will say,
um,
yeah,
I mean if,
if,
if my songs were like,
like she gets it,
you know,
it'd be different if I had a hit song with like,
like women are cunts or just something like that.
You know,
just like my mom's got a Harry Bush or something and you know,
she understands what I'm,
where I'm coming from,
whether it actually digs it cause she has her first,
his reaction was like,
you've got such a pretty voice and why don't you just keep it clean.
I'm always like,
hmm,
what's,
what's my,
my thing is again,
back to thanking you guys,
it's just like now that you got youtube and streaming services and like why do
it,
why the fuck?
Why do I need to give you?
But the thing is like there's levels like for,
I'm thinking for like as a parent too,
there's levels of language where it's like,
oh my son curses,
you know,
and then there's like I'm the pussy king and like finger up my butt.
I figured out my bubbe was definitely the weirdest one where they're just like,
I don't know if you do.
Do you want to hear the origin of that song?
Because I was hanging out with a buddy of mine in,
I'm in Nashville,
he writes kind of hit songs for country artists and uh,
he was saying this one big star I can't name was just like,
he was talking about,
you know,
these young girls on the road,
kind of what I'm singing about.
And he's like,
you know what,
these young girls,
they don't know what they're doing.
He's like,
sometimes you just want a finger up your ass and everyone in the room's laughing
and I'm the only one who's looking.
I'm like,
that's a song.
You know,
a guy who's just like,
he can get any girl he wants but I'm going to do it right.
But he really,
but what he wants,
it's a finger up his fucking,
you know,
like you can never get what you want.
Like this dude just,
we can only get off of the finger up his ass.
And I was like,
again,
I guess I'm the only guy in country music who would say that's a song right
there.
But I think they're definitely,
although they won't do,
they don't want to bring it up.
Like,
do you,
cause it's,
even though I sing me,
it's a first person song,
it's about somebody else.
But I think my parents were kind of looking at me like,
do you get off on a finger up your course?
Their thing?
Yeah.
They're worried.
Like when did we,
when did wheeler and start doing that.
Yeah.
Because if you want to know the truth,
which is,
I even,
I've heard people say that they actually enjoy like at the doctor,
like I fucking hate.
Like I owe the,
I'm the opposite.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think that's pleasurable.
I know people who've say they fucking dug it,
the checkup.
I mean,
I could see if they can say they're digging it during sex,
but like the check of it.
Yeah.
I don't want nothing near my ass.
So the,
I mean,
I don't either.
I pride myself on my honesty,
but I guess I'm just proven that that one's not elements about somebody else.
But yeah,
that's definitely,
but that's another universal theme.
I mean,
I think a lot of men would,
would it resonates with,
I want a finger in my butt.
Yeah.
I think the bigger idea was,
again,
not this specific part of it,
but just the idea of just like the weird shit people are into.
I wonder how many people like,
and these towns you go to end up there because someone else is like,
hey,
you know,
this guy likes going to be in town and like,
I got tickets and he's like,
he's is a singer.
Yeah,
he's great,
he's great.
And someone just like,
all right,
I'll go.
And they're just,
you know,
they're in the country and they're just like,
let's see what this dude is all about.
The best part is all the,
you know,
the do's with a backward baseball,
hats singing because we end the show with which one you queer.
It's going to suck my dick and watching a whole crowd just like,
dude,
just like scream that at me.
Yeah.
Just like what are they going to do with the energy?
Are they going to go home and blow each other?
I don't even know.
Yeah.
I think that's what's going to happen.
I have noticed as the crowds expanding more,
we're definitely seeing more women and more diverse crowd.
Cause yeah,
those first,
especially the first dates on that first tour,
it was just me.
It was a saw the sausage.
It's just dudes,
which you can't really put out shit like this and complain when it's all done.
Well,
I mean,
honestly as,
as a lady,
I,
I would be like,
this guy's really funny.
I feel like I get it.
Uh,
I don't know if I would go to a show cause I'm like,
is it,
is it going to be a bunch of dudes?
Are they going to tear me apart?
Yeah.
No,
it's not.
It's not like that.
But you're saying there's women there.
So that was great.
It
is,
I think is now.
I think it's like a liberating,
it's like I work all fucking week and then Friday night I'm going to get drunk
and listened to these fucking,
and I'm going to good music.
I'm going to dance and sing about pussy.
Yeah,
right,
and there's salt it.
Listen,
I mentioned plenty of Dick's and yeah,
right.
There's Dick's and pussies is what you're saying.
Yeah.
It's a good time for a,
actually,
I forgot to,
my manager was going to text and say which shows we're hurting the most.
I could mention them here,
but he never texted back,
so fire his ass.
That's what I'm trying to think what it is.
Just the audiences are so weird too because we do find in the south,
but our best audiences for whatever reason,
the fucking west coast really,
we sell out all up and down the west coast.
SARS or west coast.
West Coast is great.
Yeah.
I think it's maybe it's just that you don't get much country.
I guess he popped possibly or maybe just your themes resonate.
You know you had maybe they like it up the ass here a little bit more.
A little bit.
A little more honest about it.
What was it like,
um,
by the way,
how much effort do you think?
Like what type of thinking,
planning and time goes into Johnny Depp getting ready to go out.
I know,
like,
look,
I know,
you know he's from my hometown.
Why?
Really?
And I knew his cousin and his,
his cousins left.
I don't want to say the guy's name,
but I thought death was a stage name.
It's not,
I know his cousin,
his last name is Deb.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I mean,
isn't this like,
just the coordination.
Well he's,
but he's dressing like the pirate that he plays.
Yeah,
he's big on running jokes.
Fucking scarves.
And they know.
What did he say the other day that he was going to like shoot the president?
Yeah,
he made like some and then he had,
he did,
he issued an apology the next day.
You got to watch that shit cause they can,
yeah.
You can't say that shit man.
You don't want to be sure if you're like that famous.
You're like that guy who's probably,
he's probably doing drugs all the time.
You can't have this secret service fucking watching you all the time.
No.
Yeah,
he was like,
what was the last time an actor shot the president?
Which do that again?
Yeah.
That kind of thing.
That's actually really hard to do,
to accessorize like that.
That's theoretically a like a,
just a shot that somebody grabbed,
but that looks fucking pose
does hell right.
And that's,
that's just him that at that thing.
But I mean,
that was bullshit.
You gotta take all this off to shower.
That's what I'm saying.
That's all I shower.
Yeah.
Matt,
you're meeting a girl fucking like you.
If you meet a girl and just fucker,
I've after this,
like she's gonna get her with her ass fucking bruise with all that metal banging
against her.
It's just like,
it's a lot.
The thing that I,
that I would not,
I don't buy about this at all,
is that he's just like,
I just put this on,
you know,
like I just,
I got up and I got dressed.
No you didn't.
Yeah.
I grabbed my keep and take it to a chain and put it around my neck.
I got my eight scarf,
sal and I got out my 15 wristbands or necklaces.
I think he's trying to be Keith Richards.
I heard that.
He really loves him.
Yeah.
Well that,
that character,
the pirates character's supposed to be based on Keith Richards.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's probably what it is too.
And I think Keith Richards is honestly,
I think Keith Richards is like actually does probably fucking sleep in that shit
and a bunch of shit and then just grab shit to go.
Like right.
That's pissy.
He's probably legit.
Yeah,
you're probably right.
So much energy.
And I always admire that kind of,
that level of accessorizing on women.
Like I talk a lot of thought,
but it's not useful.
Like I swim a lot.
I have to take off every fucking Chatchki and the,
and the earrings and
isn't it too much true that he's like,
you know,
he's like the star,
but he's like a big,
he's a kid star basically.
You know this guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's like,
you know,
crazy fucking dude who looks like that.
Who's was like his big hits are all kids movies now.
Right?
It's like Willy Wonka and stuff.
True.
Do you want to,
do you want to do one more before we were bounce?
Do you want me to,
yeah,
it's fantastic.
Love it.
I'll do one off off the new record.
Yeah.
Um,
what's it,
what's it called?
There's what's called Summers in Kentucky.
Sometimes people get a,
uh,
a couple of radio stations.
Occasionally you'll see them in the charge and the,
some of the titles of the songs are clean.
Yeah.
You can get themselves in a little less.
You see trouble by playing summaries in Kentucky.
We can play that.
Oh,
he's in,
he's on the billboard charts and summertime stuff is nice.
That's really funny.
There's a video for this too though.
I was really happy with.
And by the way,
the one you sang before,
uh,
what was the first one?
Fuck you bitch that has a video.
That's a video.
That one shot up.
That one had it.
Like I said,
black Twitter must be huge cause we had a huge couple of weeks.
That's awesome man.
So this is summers in Kentucky off the new album.
All Wheeler Wheeler buy it on iTunes or Amazon or my website because we're
having trouble like those charts and not to kiss my own ass,
but I will.
Those charts are,
it means something to me because it's not a level playing field,
it's my fault.
But you know,
all the other guys are selling out if fucking Starbucks,
Walmart best buy and there's giant racks of fucking,
you know Chris Stapleton who I love Simpleton,
but you know,
he's got giant racks of his shit at Walmart that people throw in their cart and
selling 50,000 a week.
It's just Walmart dam and I fucked up.
I fucked it up.
I'm singing this garbage.
This is summers in Kentucky.
[inaudible] else.
I was just 16 [inaudible] dark down by the [inaudible] change
meeting girls on the road who are half my age.
Sometimes I think about the [inaudible].
I miss that precipice.
Now you've had a couple of kids in itself stretch.
Dale [inaudible] starting to thing when we can figure it out.
[inaudible]
perfect.
Bring your flabby ass black
looking pretty rough.
My favorite part is that you mentioned before you saying it you in trouble.
I can just see approach drink program director.
That's about as Grambling from his office that that's,
that's about as far as I go with a serious song before it turned because that's
a song I was back in Kentucky and around Thanksgiving and I'm,
a bunch of my friends were like,
let's go to our high school reunion.
I'm like,
I didn't want to go,
but I'm with them.
Like let's just go.
And it was that same old thing like you know,
there's the hot girl from high school and like man,
she looks disgusting.
And they were like,
of course we're all just like,
look at us,
we're,
we're fucking worse.
And also like we'd still fucker and sure she'd had 12 kids and he always wore
marriages or whatever it was.
And we're just like,
you know,
I,
I don't think I could have written that song without that kind of stretched up
pussy language.
You know,
it's,
it's a different song,
you know like,
but that definitely the visual of people just being like,
oh it's on the charts price and have this firing.
Well we did for fun was we sit,
what you do is,
I don't know how much you know about radio,
but you,
you do this where you set,
you have a big announcement where see that the song's going to radio and you in
the next week in the trade you put out,
you know,
like 50 ads.
Like how many stations added across the country.
So we actually sent that song to radio to country radio and then took out a big
ad the next week.
He said,
you know,
picked up my pictures and said thanks to country radio zero ads because we got
to add it to zero station controversial because at that week what they do is
they sh on this these fucking stupid like zero stations.
Yeah.
Billboard puts the chart,
you know,
you know so and so.
It got,
Garth got the g man got 50 ads,
whatever and actually they usually don't print it because everyone got zero.
They usually don't print zero,
but they printed me,
we Walker Junior Summers and Kentucky's zero ads.
Wow,
that's too bad.
That's their loss because I really think your song does,
like you say,
reflect reality.
That is your tits get soggy and cats.
It's almost like it's 2017 why can't you say dirty words?
I mean I understand that it's the law,
but I mean it's silly.
Why can't you fucking curse?
I mean I see as an SNL like kind of strutting around it.
You know I saw Chappelle doing some crazy shit on there.
Yeah.
Why can't you just say pussy?
It's not,
who cares?
Here's why I don't understand is what I said before is like I heard pussy on
meet the press.
I heard Trump saying,
you know,
play that clip.
It's like,
so if I said it in like a mean way,
it would work.
I gas if,
yeah,
if it's a,
if it's a pejorative way,
women,
I've seen it like in a meme or something,
but it's still kind of crazy that now when they,
when they talk about that,
that pussy audio and that clip,
the one guy,
one of the guys in this conversation got fired,
right.
And the other guy is president of the United States,
the guy that actually said it is president,
but we're still going to act like it's something that we,
nobody can say you're here,
you know?
Yeah,
exactly.
It's like mmm,
you could.
I mean
I assumed,
I just assumed like everyone else it was you.
You can't say grab him by the,
and now they just that he's always like you.
I'm the smartest fucking guy.
I'm like,
I'm so smart.
It's like,
ew,
ew.
Ew.
You grab,
you bragged about grabbing people by the pussy with a microphone on,
like,
come on man.
Like get the games.
That was a great song.
That was awesome.
It was really funny.
Yeah.
We'll uh,
listen to listeners,
listen to the album version because this producer did an amazing job on that
one.
I don't like,
well check it out.
Look,
get the album is called Ole Wheeler,
Wheeler Walker Jr.
Um,
and uh,
go see him live in concert.
Go to Wheeler Walker Jr com.
And also while you're at it,
pick up the old one.
The first one,
a redneck shit.
What's his real,
that's enough because like I said,
it's,
it's been this podcast world that's really keeping me alive.
Well,
there's no one else that'll have me,
they're going to support you for sure man.
And it's,
but it's this whole new,
it's really,
it's almost like underground radio in a way.
It's this whole,
this whole new thing,
which people are underestimating,
you know,
like they've been underestimating it,
but they're,
they're starting to come around.
Like I said,
I had a top.
You're not going to get any other top 10 country artists stopping by here.
I don't think that it's like our first,
but it's like they should.
They should.
Why wouldn't they?
You know,
they're smart.
You're,
you're a trailblazer.
You're unique,
you're outcast.
And I think that's why people appreciate your work.
Thank you.
I'll help.
It keeps going because
I gotta make this money back.
No,
you're going to,
um,
check it out.
Check out that you guys as always for listening to our podcast and,
uh,
here's an ass liquor by our paths on the way out of again.
Thank you
to our guests.
Wheeler Walker Jr.
Great.
This is my,
this is a great podcast.
Thank you very much.
We are for me to be okay with his feet.
Me and licking his aides.
Terror,
terror
leaking.
You
got to be
[inaudible]
take care of me.
Terror,
terror,
terror.
Yeah.
What's in it for me?
I'm like your ass.
Okay.